Sweet. The Joe Rogan experience
podcast is brought to you by the foot.
We do like these two commercials
before we actually get the flashlight.
Yeah,
we do a flash light commercial in a
commercial for on at.com but they're very
informal. So if you want to add a
jug, Ben, even if it's derogatory,
it's free speech. We
don't mind. Um, feel free.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast
brought to you by fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click
on the link for the flashlight,
you enter in the code name rogue
and you will save yourself 15%.
So that's what we're all about.
We're all about saving you some money,
giving you a better deal than life is.
You should switch up the fleshlight. Yeah.
At [inaudible] ads and like
mix up boys are about, yeah,
I should just confusing that wouldn't be,
that's how appeal of paying you for it.
Can't do that.
I'm just trying to keep my mouth shut
because I don't want to be like the first
time you had me out and
costs you your sponsors.
I've never looked at a flashlight
and went, oh man, fuck.
The shit of the concept of it
is super creative is a, yeah.
It's like you took an
apple core to a person.
This is all I'm looking forward
just despite, no, it's creepy.
And how do you hold it? You just
grab it. It's fairly textured.
It's got like ridges to it. It's kind
of a slippery, yeah. Sort of a device.
I don't know why I'm
uncomfortable talking about this.
It's an uncomfortable subject.
It just is. Uh, but the,
but the Dildo isn't it? No, not
really. I mean women can laugh about,
especially when they call it a vibrator.
Yeah.
A dildo is like a big sloppy thing.
I'm a vibrator is like,
you know, up the tool of empowerment
and I've never been doing standup.
And then there's a bachelor party comes
in and guys have flashlights hanging on
there.
He's getting married, he's
getting married. Oh my
God.
We were in Vegas this past weekend and a
whole table full of people actually got
up in the restaurant and said,
we have a bachelor right here.
And they wanted everybody
to clap for, oh, so crazy.
It's the worst part of our job.
But this wasn't even at a comedy club.
Just a restaurant.
This is just a restaurant.
A woman just cut up and what is it that
I didn't say anything. He just said, hey,
good luck with that.
I just didn't 50% end in divorce.
I didn't even, I said, Huh,
okay. Just do your thing. You
know, don't be too imposing.
Well, people can't comprehend an
evening without being about themselves.
That's what's the most
frustrating thing right now. Well,
I think it's also for a lot of people,
they don't like what they do.
They don't like their,
their situation.
And when they have a moment
for it to be special for them,
like you feel like a
Bachelorette party is like,
that's that girl is getting married. All
right, boom. It's her night. You know,
she owns it.
Right.
And so it's sort of gives you this weird
cultural license to just be off fucking
terrible. Odd. Yeah. Yeah. And he away
in a way that you never should be.
You'd never should be the one look at me.
Look at me like who the fuck is
that person? Yeah, I uh, yeah, I,
well we got,
we should get to your next sponsor.
Factionalism told wait
knows how to Fuckin Zack.
It's about professionalism. Yeah. Awesome.
We are also sponsored by on at.com
makers of Alpha brain. It's O, n n,
I t.com. Makers of Alpha brain,
shroom, tech, sport, shroom, tech,
immune and new mood.
If all these things
are nootropics and the,
a couple of them are more for
athletic performance enhancing stuff,
but the uh, what, what a nootropic
is that you should really,
if you're interested in this stuff,
you should Google it.
It's essentially vitamins that
aid and cognitive function.
It's very controversial. I've been
using them for a long time. It's um,
it's not like limitless. It's not
going to turn it more on into a genius,
but I do believe it has a positive
effect on the way your brain works.
And there's, there's been studies to back
this up and more being done right now.
But the most important thing with me if
I got behind anything is to make sure
that nobody feels like they're getting
ripped off. So because of that,
the first 30 pills, when you buy
30, you know your first order,
you get a 100% money back guarantee.
If you try it, you don't believe in it.
You're not into it though. You
don't feel it. You think it sucks.
You don't even have to send it back.
You just say this stuff sucks.
You get your money back. It's
that easy. Use The coast. Uh,
you use the code word Rogan
and save yourself 10%. And uh,
that's on a.com. O. N. N. I. T.
All right ladies and gentlemen,
Bobcat Goldthwait is here.
Thanks for having me. Yeah, thanks for
being on. We're going to play music.
I don't know why we had
to do this experience
day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
I know a few other people's
podcast recently and uh,
a lot of people are turning them into
radio shows. They're like really produced.
I don't like the, the, the,
there's a couple of them.
They are doing the commercial things
were like, they're like, all right now,
every 10 minutes or 15 minutes ago, all
right, now here's a sponsor. I hate that.
That's what a lot of them are doing now.
Adam Carolla those that it's awful. Yeah.
It's weird. Everyone's, they have a
introductions. I mean, seems really slick.
It's super slick. I'm not kissing
your ass. Your introduction is the,
the briefest to, that's good. I try to
just, yeah. Get right into the show.
Yeah. Well, sometimes it's not
though. Sometimes these flashlights,
it just goes onto a conversation about
rubber pussies that last 20 minutes.
People are hearing it now.
You're here to done iTunes. Yeah.
But they're not hearing it on a serious,
Eh, you know, whatever. Then, uh, well,
subscribe to it on iTunes.
Right.
It's definitely an extra 10 minutes
each show about rubber pussies.
Usually just the con, well, it's,
it's a weird thing like as a human being.
Like, we all know that we masturbate,
but we, you know, we're comedians and
yet we both really uncomfortable. Right.
While we're talking about
fucking this rubber pussy,
like it's a weird thing to
admit this human need it for,
you know, to, cause it's like
breaking up with your hand.
That's why I had some weird, it is
a little bit, a little bit. Yeah.
She tried to fake yourself
out. Yeah, it's definitely a fake out.
I uh, we were talking to me about,
uh, about the Bachelorette party, the,
the, the bane of the comedy a thing.
But I had a group of women in Sioux City,
Sioux falls,
I can't remember which
one, but um, came in late,
sat and took over the whole show,
just wouldn't shut up, you know, and,
and I do my stock Glines about quieting
people down and they're not going to,
and they're going to make it all about
themselves the whole night. And, uh,
it got to the point where the
crowds are, they going, you know,
kick them out and stuff.
And then finally, like,
I have this rage that I don't love or
I'm proud of, but you know, it's there.
And so it's so fun. I go, okay, you
want the show to be about you. You know?
And it's like, whoa. And I really
don't know what I'm saying during that.
I'm serious. It's just like, Oh
ah, you know, and Sanger just pure.
Yeah. And so I stopped because the
crowds cheering because by the way,
like a comedy club, people love tension.
They love conflict. You know what I mean?
A bars never empty because you said,
hey chill guys are getting along in
the parking lot. Let's watch. So,
so the crowds cheering and then I go back
and I started doing my act and all of
a sudden one of the women in the middle
of the group stands up and she's sobbing
and she goes, I'm not a
whore. It's my birthday. Oh.
Cause apparently in the
middle of the Diageo
he called her a whore and I remember it.
Wow. I'm not a whore. It's my birthday.
That's a good tee shirt.
Maybe that'll be my, uh,
that's going to be my good are done.
That's going to be mine.
I'll be selling them after shows.
We get through that a,
it's my birthday. I show hold a
tee shirt up at the end of my set.
It is bizarre how many people that think
they have like some license to be a con
because it's their birthday.
Well, just, just so weird.
It's my birthday weekend too.
It's not the just one day anymore.
It's like the whole week
and guys do it also.
Like I saw a guy the other day
was his birthday and I'm like,
when is your birthday? I don't want to
say hit the comic is, and he's just like,
oh, it was Wednesday. And I'm like,
you're telling everyone to buy his shots.
It's Friday. Your birthday was two
days ago. You're a grown man. What?
The hours were long weird. Is it to get
super excited? Hey about your birthday,
but be about like the days are
rounded, right? Your birthday. Wow.
What the fuck?
I had a birthday Saturday and uh,
that was, uh, it's depressing.
I turned 50 but everyone always thinks
I'm a lot older. Right? They always think,
because I look, I know, I
know I'm not aging gracefully,
but people always think I'm a lot older.
But I got on Letterman was 27
doing this for a long time. Man,
Boston, a Boston by weight. But I also
started like in Syracuse and then,
and then,
and then I moved to Boston was like 18.
You were a part of that crazy time
period of Boston comedy, Boston comedy.
Like if you look back at all the
great comedians that came out of that,
that one town really incredible
even right. And Jay Leno and you know, I
mean there's so many guys when he Clark,
there were so many great
guys that came out of Boston
when I was there.
It was Steve Wright and uh,
Paula Poundstone and well, a lot
of guys are still there. Like Tony,
me and Barry Crimmins, Kenny Rogers
in and Mike Dunn at Sweeney. Yeah.
All those guys. Uh, it was a
really, really, really crazy part,
but I didn't realize it.
I guess it wasn't
that crazy and other cities and it
must've been right. I don't know. I mean,
I think that was the,
I think that spot your spot in the 80s
was it like it was like early eighties,
like 80 yeah.
That was like the,
I think that was like the
best spot ever in the country.
I don't think there's ever
been that many great comedians.
It came out of one spot, but it was one
of them that people don't even know about
Jordy of the comedy clubs at that time
in Boston we're kind of ran and booked by
the comics. So that's why. And like if
you were derivative of someone else,
you would get kind of iced
out of a scene and stuff. So
you, yeah, you're, you had
a really original group. It
was a very original group,
but it was really insane.
I remember being like with uh,
I dunno why he would
tell a story like this,
but I remember like I don't drink or take
drugs and people don't know that cause
cause I always seem like I'm
fucked up anyways. You know?
But you don't do anything. No, no.
And I haven't since I was 19. Wow.
Those crazy performances that you did
completely stone sober. Yeah. Yeah.
It makes him ever more
impressive and frightening.
Oh. But he was kind
of, I think it's weird.
It's like people will blame drugs
for that stuff and it's like,
what are you on drugs? You don't scream
and run around, you know what I mean?
What kind of drugs are you on?
Like what makes you do that?
You know? Uh, but yeah,
but I think like, uh,
like really straight people assume that
that's what happens when you're on drugs.
You know what I mean? Right. That's funny.
Yeah. You're like a fake drugged out guy.
Like when Charlie Sheen was
having his manic episodes,
instead of feeling bad for
the guy, everybody was like
going, oh, he's on drugs.
You know?
That's,
that's someone who's a huge nerd that's
never done drugs saying that he's on
drugs. You know? It's like when
you're on drugs, you don't go,
I need a press conference.
You know, you're on drugs,
you stand here in the closet thinking
black helicopters are flying over under
the couch. I mean, if you're
having bad experiences on drugs,
I think that's why people
don't think I'm sober either,
because I'm not one of these annoying
people that thinks people shouldn't be on
drugs. You know? I, you know,
I'm not against them. I just,
I blew it, you know what I mean? But I,
I feel uncomfortable around people
who don't drink or take drugs,
you know what I mean? Like, well,
I think that's part of growing up doing
comedy where I did two or the life I
grew up as a kid,
but I remember being in Boston and this
was when I still did drink and, uh,
doing drugs. I was doing
a, I remember that I,
I'm embarrassed to say I was doing
coke because coke is so douchey.
It's the ax Cologne of drugs,
you know? Yeah. And, and,
and it was like four 35 in the morning,
maybe even earlier. It was earlier,
because what we, uh, what we had done, it
had all the windows at the Ding Ho, uh,
cardboard boxes. So people sort of
light couldn't come in. And, well,
it's just like all these comics drinking
and partying and it's like the door
swings open and home. Was it? What
time? We mean when the day, yeah,
it was like morning because
when the door swung open,
all this sunlight poured in and these
cops like backlit fill the door and I'm
like, wow, I'm going to jail. And
then the cops were like, Lenny, Lenny,
you fucking prick. How are you friends?
And then I just sat down and started
drinking and partying with us and I was
like, 18 years old ago, I'm going to
jail. Oh, this is my scene and blow.
This is the best scene
ever. You know, it's funny,
when I was in below the night before,
I had some sort of cold and I,
and I couldn't feel my
nose and I was like, oh,
this is what it was like to do
coke, you know, I, I, you know,
so I ad libbed the line in this movie,
what was the wig budget on this moment?
I ad libbed Lyda, I
can't feel my face, which
it was. Uh, it's very 50.
Fuck me. Running 160. Jesus Christ,
the 170, 180, a hundred,
187.
Where did you get this stuff?
Oh, uh, oh. Do you mind if I do online?
Fuck it.
Let's all do one.
She mentioned doing coke with p.
It was a,
we're doing baby laxative here. Oh
really? Yeah. I just shit a lot, Derek.
I Shat a willow tree.
Uh,
what am I supposed to do with all
this solid Jesus Christ. George,
I don't see you in two years and you show
up at my fucking door with 110 pounds
a blow. Just fucking sell
it. They're all right.
But it's going to take me a year.
I can't feel my face.
I mean I can touch it,
feel it inside.
So that's the scene. I actually, uh,
you know, uh, w when I say,
where did you get this? Uh,
Johnny Depp actually hadn't lived a
funny line. He goes, my dentist. But
it was funny cause he's turns
out he's a very funny guy.
But I did say this when I was filming
that scene and it became in my standup,
I hate to be corny and do a story
from my standard, but it is true.
I didn't really know those guys
at well at all. And uh, I go,
is anybody in this scene not on probation?
And Johnny Depp's like what did you do?
I go, I said, the tonight show I'm fired.
He's like, yeah, why did you do that?
I go, I dunno, I thought it was funny.
And then I'm like, you smashed it,
that hotel. He goes, yeah, I go,
were you drunk? And Johnny Depp
is funny. He goes, in my defense,
the hotel room made the first move
and this is a true story cause then I
look over at Paul Reubens and he's just
trying to ignore the conversation.
It wasn't like, hey yeah, I rubbed
weird rock and roll thing.
The trash, the hotel room,
have accountants pay for it all.
But I've always felt like
during, there was a period where I was
trashing television shows, you know,
and it was just, I had the same kind of
frustration and rage and I thought, well,
if I do it at a Holiday Inn, you know,
big deal. Why don't I do it on a TV show?
That's kind of funny at least.
Yeah,
I know.
That makes no sense.
Look at me like that RCA victor
dog just then staring at me.
I'm going to kind of see your
point, but I don't, I mean,
I don't see the point of doing hotel
rooms. I've never understood it.
Just smashing shit and like, what are
you doing? That's just out of boredom.
But I'm the rule, but it's so
stupid to me. Just so childish.
Me, I couldn't do that because I'd be
afraid of waking up people next door.
I'm serious.
Like I have no problems sending the
tonight still on fire or or, yeah.
Or smashing up the ice Sidney hall show.
But the idea of,
I don't want to put somebody else out.
You smashed Arsenio Hall shows too.
What did you do there? Yeah. Way crazier
than the tonight show. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Cause he got fired,
you know, because of a,
they put Chevy Chase on and
70 markets in front of them.
So paramount kind of fucked him over.
So I went out and I said,
are you really quitting? It was like the
week or two before. And he goes, yeah.
And I go, well let's not make
it easy on them, you know.
So I spray painted paramount
sucks on the backdrop.
And then I,
uh,
I started throwing the couches into the
audience and the crowd was going crazy.
Oh. And then I remember I
took a television set and
monitor and just threw it and
then put my, uh, put my work boots
through the back of it. She's crying.
She's way more expensive than anything
I did on the tonight show. But yeah.
So then they,
they like tell Arsenio like get him.
And so he wrestles me down and as
he's got me on the ground, he goes,
thank you man.
Well cause it,
cause it was such a colossal
fuck you. And then like,
you know, a week later,
Jay had booked me on the tonight
show, you know, which end,
he came in the dressing room
and he's like, you know, don't,
don't smash up to more
stuff. You know, cause,
cause they were hoping and
I'd do something fucked up.
Now I'm not blaming them.
I mean I wasn't,
that was a bit of the green light.
Oh
yeah. I mean I knew that I was on there
to do something screwy, but, but uh,
you know, what made it arson
was that I actually had the, uh,
this uh, lighter, a barbecue, lighter
taped to my wrist. Like I was like,
that's what made it arson.
Yeah.
Because it meant that it was a
predetermined yeah, exactly. Yeah.
It was like a taxi driver.
Do you didn't worry about doing,
we worried we did that nobody was on fire.
I mean,
cause I knew it burden clean
and the lighter fluid and stuff.
And then I also had a
buddy, I said, you know,
stand next to this fire extinguisher if
it gets out of control. But, but you know,
uh, I, I don't mean that.
Make this my hook cause I've talked
about it on other podcasts but,
but I guess it's good to clean, clear
the air, you know? But um, I don't know.
People think like I was
banned from the tonight show,
but they had me on immediately right
after. And it was, it was weird.
What was weird was see is a lot bigger
than I always try to make Aiga. That's it.
The little fire.
Jesus Christ.
Well that's cause I'm squirting
lighter fluid right there.
Why? Why, why did you do that?
I love that I show to get ready and
this is like speechless twice now.
He just looking at why,
I mean I can,
I guess you were pissed off, but I mean,
I guess you know what it is. You're,
you're, you're, you're, um, I don't know.
I mean I think maybe you're too hippie.
You know what I mean? I think it's funny.
You know, you're the mixed martial
artists guy and I've got more rage,
which is really weird. Oh, it's
probably just because I exercise.
So you get it all out,
get it all out physically so you don't,
what about laying on stage?
Do you ever snap?
Very rarely. I mean, if I do,
I, it's for fun and I don't,
you know what I mean?
Like No. It's like, oh,
that's like part of what
you know to shut someone up.
You have to get into a rage.
But am I actually enraged? No,
I'm just doing what I have to do
to keep the show rolling. Yeah.
Well I got to feel more pity for people
like that than anything at this point.
But like a heckler, hecklers, just
anyone who just completely over,
over anxious to get attention.
Just obnoxious.
Moronica I feel bad for them.
I feel bad that that people are at that
stage in their life where they're just
so fucking stupid. They want to yell out
in the middle of his show and interrupt.
What about winning?
It's like when, when look,
when they do that and they,
and they make it so you can't do your ad,
then you have to go after though. Right.
I try not to be actually angry though.
Yeah. If that makes any sense. You know,
I understand. It's like what I was saying
like that rage, it's like a switch.
It's like a, it's like a tool
that I have that I'm not proud of,
but unfortunately it doesn't
really boil up in my real life.
I do think people think that might be
out of control and the rest of my life,
I don't think I am. Why do you
like what? You seem very friendly.
I don't, I don't think of you as a guy
that would be like filled with rage.
I think of you,
it was a guy who
probably would have rage if you felt like
someone was fucking with you. Yeah. And,
and, and it's Corny and played out. And I,
I really don't have any
patients for bullying, which,
which I hate that term now.
Like people use it. It's so, uh,
it doesn't mean the same thing, but,
but yeah, I don't, I don't like bullies,
bullies, uh, ever since I
was a little boy, you know,
but if you think that the
world should be a adjust place,
you do spin out a lot, you know?
I mean, so I mean, you know, I,
I dunno,
I think and I don't actually,
I'm not helping my case cause we talked
a little bit about my new movie a,
if people see that they think
I'm angry too, you know,
it's okay. So spoiler alert,
maybe a baby does get shot
in the first two minutes.
Oh look,
it's not a real break of view.
Joe Ever seen a baby gets shot.
Whoa. That isn't, well in my defense
that baby wasn't asshole. No,
it was a baby. It's a, oh
well there's the jailer,
but I think someone's posted the jeep
of the baby getting shot. Holtzman,
no standup comic.
He's one of these guys that is
probably one of the funniest guys ever.
But for whatever reason he can never get
it together enough to write like career
and stand up.
When Susan Smith drown her kids,
he came into the comedy store and he goes,
I heard those were bad kids. He goes,
I heard they sat that close
to the television than
ever put away their blocks.
They're constantly spilling those milk.
The kids will not be missed. It was,
everybody was like Holy Shit. And if
you see him as kids, like he's like,
it's really big and tense guy with
the slicked back hair and you know,
he stands right in front of them.
It was one of the funniest fucking
things I ever saw. Anybody say no.
Do you think he means that?
No. No. Yeah, character.
Cause Cause I've done that where I've
gone over the line and I've said things
that I don't believe in.
It made me feel bad later I
opened for Nirvana and uh,
and I know comics are always like, oh,
you know, getting heckled and stuff,
you know.
I mean I got hit with teenagers.
They would successfully throw people
from the pit and hit me and I had
[inaudible] going off around me and
I get hit with bibles a lot too,
which was weird. Whoa. Wow.
Yeah. And so boots and stuff.
So I learned like I learned like the
Serpentine, you know what I mean?
I would just go back. How many times did
you open for that? I did, I think like 16,
17 shows and every once in a while he
would go, okay. Which was weird, you know,
but I was more comfortable
when it was horrible.
I know that sounds weird,
but that was my,
that felt right to do.
You know what I mean?
He deserved no, I just thought
it was kind of funny. You know,
like when you get laughs,
that means the crowd likes you.
When you get like rage, that means
you have all of their attention.
Do you know what I mean? Like Robin
Williams is my good friend and Robin,
you know,
he goes on stage and people love him and
then I would go on after him when we do
sets and, and, and, and in a weird way,
it meant more for me for people to go,
oh, Robin Williams showed up last night.
Yeah. And then Bobcat Goldthwait
was there. Do you know
what that fucking asshole,
and a weird way that meant more to me,
you know,
his form of neuroses is way
more lucrative. You know, my,
I'm telling people to fuck off isn't
as lucrative, but uh, but yeah,
so it was opening for Nirvana in Chicago
and Michael Jordan every tired from
basketball. And I went,
Hey Chicago, by the way,
they hated me to begin with, but I go,
Hey Chicago, I feel bad, but you know,
for $40 million a year, I'd shoot my
own dad in the fucking head, you know?
And there was a noise that wasn't
even like a Bu. It was just like,
fuck you.
I wish I had that sample.
It was the best.
And
what did you think at that moment when you
heard that? It was funny, you know, but,
but I did, you know, I don't have a beef
with Michael Jordan. I felt bad. I mean,
even though,
cause people just because they're super
famous doesn't mean they're still not
human. So I did, I go, why'd I do that?
But you know, so he had to live in,
you learn it's baby steps, but the
only person laughing that night really,
I remember walking by Kirby
on the amp and he goes,
I can't believe you said
that. But yeah, I had uh, met,
uh, Nirvana. I met Kurt before they broke.
He was a fan of mine and
wanted to interview me.
So he interviewed me at a
college radio station in Anarbor.
I know that blows people's mind.
It's like finding out that like a Jimmy
Hendricks really loved Buddy Hackett or
something. But uh, yeah, he did.
I love that.
Talking Duck Moose.
It blew my mind. Wow. That's
pretty fucking cool. Yeah.
So I toured in the open forum.
I repelled in nude from the roof of the
Oakland Coliseum on new years when the,
with them cause they were playing
there. And uh, and uh, yeah.
Are you called, did you meet Courtney?
Where you around Courtney a little bit,
yeah. You see their relationship?
Yeah, I mean the, what I saw actually,
I don't have any, uh, any good dirt for
people. They seem to like each other.
I'm not, you know, I, I, uh, I,
you know, I think people, you know,
I,
you know,
people get involved in all this crazy
conspiracy stuff and all that stuff.
I think what happens with some things,
and I know where I am when I'm
talking about crazy conspiracy,
but sometimes I think like huge tragedies
happen and people can't justify them,
so they have to make up some other thing.
You know what I'm saying?
I think sometimes it's, it's,
it's just, um, you know,
I, I, you know, Kurt was a really
sweet guy, but he certainly was a,
a manic depressive. And I
almost think like, again,
when we were talking about earlier,
people are talking about drugs, it's like,
like that killed them. It's
like, well, that didn't really
kill him. You know, he, he,
he had some in his system when
he died, but he, he, he, he,
he'd cleaned up enough to commit suicide.
You know,
there's some people that
are chemical imbalances.
There's some people that
are prone to suicide.
And I think blaming drugs is
really lazy, you know? Well,
certainly upsets the balance though,
right? I mean, I swear to God,
I'm 30 years sober and I'm
saying this, but, but you know,
I think it's just easy to blame drugs.
Oh, well yeah, I see what you're saying.
I mean it's, it's a personal
choice, right? I mean,
to get to get addicted in the first place.
Yeah. But I don't think all addictions,
I think with think heroin kills.
I think running out of heroin kills.
So what does heroin, you know,
not good, but whatever. Well,
I look, the only time I've been
high, high in the past 30 years,
I had back surgery and I was on
dilaudid and uh, I'll tell you what, uh,
I certainly didn't have any suicidal
thoughts that fucking week and a half.
That was beautiful.
I'm not gonna lie,
it's essentially like an
opium lucky experience.
My wife came home and I was
crying watching lifetime.
This is the story
and watching a lifetime show marquis post
is still going to take away your son.
And
my wife goes,
you don't get any more.
I was just crying.
That sounds awesome.
That would've been great to videotape
people like those fucking pills, man.
Is that what I see going on July?
Cause at the same thing. I
don't know. I never done it,
but I'm assuming it is opiates.
Yeah. Scared of that shit.
Yeah, it's bad times, man. Because
it's the, it's the, it's the,
the need and the getting off of
them, which are horrible. I've heard,
I don't know why we're talking so much
about drugs today, but it's all right.
Do you have any,
did you document your time with Nirvana
at all with curt or anything like that
at that time? New. Did you have like an
video cam and you kept around? I have a,
I have,
I have seen a photo of me nude behind him,
stage with the,
I have the in Nutro wings on and I'm
naked with a repelling little thing and
then I love them back. And I
also have a hat on. I like that.
I don't mind people seeing my dick when
my love handles, but not my balding pate,
you know? So I've got
a hat. I will say this,
if you're a comedian or perform and
you're going to be nude publicly,
give it a tug. You'll, you'll thank
me later cause uh, yeah, it was cold.
I really wish I did pull my Dick. How
many photos are there of that out there?
Surprising. Not a ton.
You know, this was, uh,
was in the mid nineties,
I guessing. Right.
Did they have even have digital though
now? It would have been everybody's phone.
Yeah. But still, I mean it wasn't
hot. It was just weird, you know,
there was so much ma'am going on stage
too, by the way, cause it was midnight,
you know, fireworks were going
off. It was just like, oh yeah.
And there's Bob Scratch Goldfarb
nude walking around like a chair.
I was, we were going to,
the way that it was set up,
it was men, you know, New Year's.
So they wanted to do an extra
thing where there's explosions.
And I remember saying, the curt, I said,
you know, you know, I go, fuck you man.
I'm tired of being your scatter. That was
Elvis's chimp, you know, fuck you man.
I don't want to cheer you up, you know,
go called Pauly shore's something.
You know. So, uh, when we,
when we set up the thing about me
repelling, the guy took a cult,
the stage manager took cold cuts
and he built the stage out of the,
out of the food tray in the back. And
he's like, okay, here's what Chris's,
here's Dave years curtain and Bob's
going to repel in nude in these m and m's
are where the explosives
are. It's so, and so, um, I,
it's still, they go, Kurt will count,
we'll tell you when it's midnight,
you count back from 10 or whatever,
you know. [inaudible] okay, so,
so, uh, it's midnight and they
give them the sing though.
And he looks up and I'm holding my
own weight, like rappelling down,
but I stopped, you know, so he can
count. And so I'm giving them the Brown.
I basically, from 150 feet up,
he goes, he looks up and he goes,
Hey, Oakland, you want
to hear a drum solo?
And so I'm barely control my own way.
And then finally he just goes one.
And I,
and I shot down really fast.
I had rope burns on my ass and stuff
and I landed right behind him, Bam.
And then, uh, I came down so
fast, he actually didn't see
it. And then you're like,
he looks up and he's like Paulie,
Paulie.
So until then I ducked behind this amp
looking for a cover because there's
supposed to be, my closers was to be there
with someone had taken him as a joke,
you know? And so I just kind of had
to stand in the middle of the stage,
cause everywhere there was bombs
going off, I learned those.
If you're nude at midnight,
you don't get a kiss.
Like everywhere I went people were like,
Whoa,
nude guy walking around a little weird.
So yeah.
So again, all this was in
sobriety. That's hilarious.
No one would have assumed I would always,
I always thought you definitely were a,
I lose a weed guy. Know
what it is, is like,
often I see something and I go, well
this, this is never going to happen again.
So I got to a Carpe Diem, man. You know, I
gotta I gotta seize the moment. You know,
when things align. Yeah. Collide
the couch on the couch up fight.
You got to dry Hump Michael Bolton.
I'm like,
once I was it dry humped
Weigel bolts. Yeah, he was,
he was singing and it was this benefit
and he was the headliner and yeah.
And uh, and so I just see
him and I'm like, well,
I'm never going to have this kind
of access to Michael Bolton again.
So I walk out behind him
and now just grab him.
I just started dry humping
him and his crew tackled me,
drag me off stage and the guy's like,
what the fuck?
[inaudible]
I'm Michael, I'm sorry this is me,
no softball tomorrow. And he's like,
just get out of here man.
So I walked and ran actually around the
whole auditorium and came up through the
other side and I started booking out
again. But I got tackled that down.
I didn't make it to him. I got like,
I didn't even get packed again.
Pass the kick drum. Did
they hurt you? No, no, no.
Cause they're used to grab and you know,
Chubby Catholic women and tackling them.
You know, not like, you know, that's the,
that's the threat at a
Michael Bolton concert.
Well you would think though that security
would want to kick your ass for doing
something like that, but it was his
security. So they wear kid gloves.
How bad ass as Michael Bolton security.
I don't know if that,
like chicks would go crazy for that game.
Bow and arrows know that for real man,
he called, we had a really hard time
keeping crazy chicks away from here.
It's better. It's not like the stones
at Oakmont hiring hell's angels.
The kickass.
Some of those clerical workers,
they're going to give us a lot of strife
today. Guys. Clerical workers. Yeah.
He represents like he's this singing
version of those really great looking good
guys that are like paintings on the cover
of those really stupid romance romance
now flowing long fiber.
Exactly. The Fabio Kinda guy.
A woman. It's a man, woman hybrid
thing. You know the long hair like that.
I mean, you see what
they're doing. I mean, why,
what men do you know that have like
open chested shirts and they have long
flowing hair? Like, oh that,
that's a ridiculous you're
yet, that's partly a woman.
They,
that's what they're looking for.
They're looking for some weird
amalgamation of man and woman.
Uber Romantic that doesn't
exist in an actual man.
Is that Guy gonna have sex with a woman.
You know what I'm saying?
Once she wants it on her terms, it's
not like a pirate. It's just like, no,
no, no. He's super romantic
lives only for her. See,
this is why this twilight thing worked.
The women founded to be a romance film.
I mean it really wasn't a vampire movie.
Well, and I mean that's the
American idol thing. It's,
it's guys who are non threatening
to old ladies and young girls.
But I think when a woman grows up, she
wants to get laid, she wants to get fuck,
she doesn't want
some do.
And they retained the need for
intense amounts of romance in,
in almost fictional form.
And that's where it bounces out in these,
these twilight to sort of things where
we don't understand it. And we'd go,
what the fuck is going on?
And yet you're seeing flocks of
women lining up to buy these books.
But I find that those women are
really arrested. I, I find them. Yeah,
they're very
did. They're very immature.
You know what I mean? I know in
a certain way or that's just what
they like and they indulge it. Yeah.
But do you think he's older women
that are like that? I don't know.
I would assume, I would assume
there's probably some, I dunno.
I'd like to, I want to know the,
uh, the ages on that. So you will,
you're thinking is that as
they get wiser and older,
that seems more and more ridiculous.
And they said the idea of running off
and with some pirate and [inaudible] sexy
hair, I don't think it's that they
really want to do that. You know?
I don't think it's like they would
really run off with the vampire.
They love reading the story about the
woman who runs off with the vampire.
She's the one for him.
I don't know anything about the twice
a Mormon version of the thing.
The woman who was a Mormon,
so she didn't even know too much
about the vampire culture, I believe.
Yeah. Well she made up a bunch of shit.
Like they can even be in the sunlight.
It just sparkle. Well, what the
fuck is he supposed to dial in?
A real band fire? Fheg
that's big. That's bullshit.
It burst into flames. Let
you see blade what? Fix me.
More of a nerd that I'm upset that they're
like, that is so bullshit. Vampires.
I got upset a blade because they got away
with the something with sunscreen and
I'm like, that is fucking,
that's his laziest fuck bullshit.
Bullshit. You can't fucking wear sunscreen
bitch. I'm calling bullshit on blame.
100% bullshit again. Yeah, I
guess that's a sensitive empire,
but that's at least better to me.
I'll,
I'll take the sunscreen over.
They sparkle.
Like you can't just reinvent the vampire.
You can't guess
Ken. I mean, but no, that's ridiculous.
But I mean there's, you know,
I mean, what universe do they really
exist in anyways? You know, I, uh,
I would not know anything
about what would make a loop
creative story.
I think they should just,
I don't think you understand. My movies
makes the cloud and I fucking loved it.
And I movies make hundreds of dollars.
So I've use the
cloud. And then I did a movie
called Windy city heat that,
that one I didn't write,
but that's when I directed and kind
of help put all the pieces together.
John Barrett, I still haven't watched
that. And then there's the heart.
World's greatest dad is a movie
I did with Robin Williams. No,
I didn't see worlds groups there. And
he's staring shakes the clown, the clown.
Well,
these movies shakes is a fucked up movie.
That's a very angry movie.
And every once in a while, uh,
like Tom Kenny and I went to a screening,
Tom Candy plays binky.
The evil clown is now
the voices spongebob.
So I always think Nickelodeon probably,
it doesn't really ever quickly drill.
I'm sure Nickelodeon,
hey,
you know the guy who's doing
coke and killing people with
Ra? Juggling pins. Yeah,
that's our, that's our,
that's our cornerstone. Yeah.
So Spongebob, I, no, Tom Kenny
since I was six years old, but,
so Tommy was a binky decline.
He and I watching shakes at this thing
and it was just packed with people and
they're just as the
characters and they were,
there was clown whores
there and everything.
It was really strange and
people were really fucked up.
And then the middle of a Tom
Kenny leans over to me, he goes,
what the fuck were we thinking?
And I'm like, I don't know man.
It was like that star trek sketch on SNL.
You know what I mean?
Like these people were really passionate
about it and I'm like, get a life.
I didn't say that I was very nice to them,
but I was a junior in high school and
shakes the clown was the first, uh,
independent move. I didn't know
what independent movies were.
And that was the first movie that I
had to go to a different movie theater.
Then I was used to,
you know,
like off the AMC and I watched it and
it was my favorite movie in high school
growing up. Uh, and uh, what,
what was weird about six to con?
Have you ever gone back to like do
like a commentary commentary on it?
Like to do that? I'd like to do
that and get everybody together. Uh,
cause I mean there's a ton of comics
in that movie that just Robin,
but there's like Adam Sandler and,
and uh,
Blake Clark and I might do that,
like get it like a case
beer and get us all together
and do it as a podcast.
If you ever want to use a studio park
as you can always use desk garden.
There we go. And then many people
would actually sink it up though.
I think a lot of people we do,
we do it a lot of times with like UFC fcs
and like TV shows and stuff like that.
But I think I like a lot of these movies
would be great to just go back and
revisit as some kind of, you
know, yeah. You know what,
that would be a cool video to
release online of you doing that.
And I bet it would really
pump up the DVD sales.
Well shakes. Uh, I don't have a
problem revisiting it. I tried,
I'm wondering if I remember many of
the stories. Uh, but I do remember it.
I ended up on the today show with a
real clown debating the program. Yeah.
Cause clowns are protesting it.
There were mad. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I just beat the guy before we go
on, I was like, what's your name?
And he's like, I'm bamboozle. And I'm
like, no dude, what's your real name?
He's like, I'm in my clown attire, so
call me by my clown name. Okay, bamboozle.
I'm going to rip you a new
one when we get out there.
So we get on TV and Katie Kirk says
this was her worst interview ever.
So we get on TV and she's
like going the clowns.
Like clowns do a lot of good for a lot
of good causes and bobcat's film portrays
them in a negative like good. And
I go, nobody thinks you're funny.
The only reason you perform and hospitals,
because that's one place that kid can't
get up and run away from you. And then,
uh, Katie Kirk's like, would you
please be serious? I was like, no,
you're interviewing me in a clown.
So would you please be serious about
this very important issue of cloud abuse,
clown clown abuse.
So I liked the fact that my dad actually
was always like saying what did you do
to kid Kirk? Cause she says you were
the worst interview like she had,
he had her back. Matt Mine, that'd
be the worst interview.
That's the worst energy
you've ever had.
And this is someone who at the time was
probably interviewing the backstreet
boys and stuff.
But so me because I came out and character
was the worst thing she'd ever seen.
The worst thing ever.
He ruined my month mo because I answered
it was my birthday month I think.
Cause I also,
she wasn't familiar with me and I think
I sacrad punchier cause I think she met
me and I was like oh hi. And then I
came out and I was like Ah. Oh I see.
Yeah.
Cause she expecting you to have some
sort of a rational debate or she couldn't
switch gears. Yeah. As you were
in character can be wigged out.
Like if I didn't know me and I met the
guy and then I come out and I'm like,
how did you create that character?
Where did that come from?
I just never felt comfortable doing
traditional stand up, you know?
So the idea of just doing this guy who
was, I wasn't comfortable on stage,
so just to be nervous,
you know,
like my early standup would just be me
reading a dear John Letter and crying a
real dear John Letter. And then cause
they'd go, Hey, please love them me back.
Get Gold and you want
to hear jokes. You know,
I'd be sobbing and it'd be
like two guys walk into a bar.
I'd read the letter and it goes,
my wife was so fat, you know,
how fed is she? I told you I don't even
have a girlfriend. You fucking listen.
You know, it wasn't, it wasn't stand of,
it was just this real weird
thing I would do. And,
and eventually people would start picking
on that character and then he would
become, I would become more
angry and, and kind of defensive.
And it became crazier and crazier.
But I also just didn't like the idea of
going out on stage and pretending I was
me because, uh, all the comics,
I always looked up to be at Groucho Marx
or Andy Kaufman or anyway, you know,
they had a persona they hid behind,
you know,
and the idea for me just to go out in a
sweater and talk about dating seems so,
it seems so foreign to me also.
I was so young too.
So that was the other
reason why it was weird.
What kind of a persona did Groucho Marx
of? Well, I mean, that's not Groucho,
you know what I mean? That, that whole,
the cadence in his voice and all that,
it painted on a mustache for God's sakes,
you know?
But I think people are pain
than most of us really? Man,
he was painting on his mustache.
Oh my God.
Was that weird seeing you? Yeah, mostly.
Mostly because I sound like a dinosaur.
I thought it was going to need a
black guy who makes the funny night.
I didn't realize that joke is so old.
I actually still have to do that
joke when people introduce me.
I thought it was good to be the black
guy. That's funny. I think it's sad that,
you know,
Bubba Smith passed away and I get a call,
the way I found out about it is I get a
call from the AP wire service and they
go, Hey, do you have a common on Bubba
Smith passing away? And I was like, well,
I didn't know he died.
And he had just died a few hours before.
And uh, yeah, I have a quote. Um,
he was a really good guy who, uh,
didn't take any bs and he was a lot
smarter than people realized and he told
great stories. That's what I was saying.
But the whole time I'm thinking, man,
when I die, I hope they don't
call fucking Gutenberg. You know,
I hope. I'm like, I didn't see Bubba
in 20 years. And they called me.
Right.
Did you see 'em Gutenberg
when something happened?
There was when Phil Hartman
was, uh, killed Gutenberg,
like dressed up in like a suit and a tie
and went down to talk to the reporters
and sort of represent celebrities
and to ask for privacy.
It was one of the weirdest
fucking things I've ever seen.
It was like he knew that cameras were
going to be there and he vaguely knew
them, so he decided to represent the
situation. It was really strange.
No, I'd never seen that. So he
goes out and he starts acting like
sort of talking to the press and
talking to, you know, it was really,
it was a really good neighborhood.
I don't even think he lived in the same
neighborhood, man just showed up there.
Yeah, I was one of those things
where I think you like blew a fuse.
He's the sergeant of arms of
show business. It was weird.
I'm the press secretary for famous people,
particularly weird for me because
you know, I was on the show,
Phil friends with them. It wasn't like,
who the fuck is this guy? This guy.
It wasn't, he wasn't like talking
about this dude all the time,
but that's the, that's the nature of
death, you know? I mean, when you die,
people have to make it
all about themselves. They
can't, they can't, you know,
that's,
now I'm being a plugfest.
But you're talking about a guy who
you actually knew passed away and then
someone tried to explain them,
but you know,
that's the plot of a world's
greatest dad kid. Spoiler alert,
Robin's son in that movie
dies rubbing one out, uh,
with a belt around his neck
and he's this horrible kid.
And then everybody at
school now loves his kid.
And he was a great friend because
Robin makes it look like a suicide.
Hangs the kid from a chin up bar and
then writes a suicide note that is way
better written than anything. This kid
who was a fucking numb nuts could ever,
right. And the kids go online and
they publish it in the school papers.
So now Robin keeps writing as
his dead son to get play. Like,
like there's a woman he's trying to bang.
It's just like going,
did Kyle writing anything
else? And he's like, yeah,
he keeps writing as his dead son.
Wow. That's bizarre. And
it's called the world. That's
great. His Dad. But there's
a scene in that, you know,
Chris from Nirvana was, and,
and Chris just had weird cameo because
Robin's son is really into a fucked up
porn, you know, like shies of porn and
all this stuff in the movie. And then, uh,
not, not Robin's real stuff. And so,
and so there's just a scene where Robin
is standing in front of a porn and he
just starts sobbing and,
and Chris plays the newsman when he
comes over and he gives him a hug.
And it's a really weird scene because
hardcore porn reminds him of his dead son.
It's a very touching, odd, fucked
up scene. Jeez. But Chris, uh,
you know, I'd say, Hey, Chris, you know,
what's the scene about? He know, he said,
what's the scene by? I go, you
know, when someone passes away,
people tend to make it all
about themselves and they
don't really make it about
the person that, or the
people that actually knew the
person. And, and Chris goes,
I have no idea what you're
talking about. So, so it's, uh,
that's one of my favorite
scenes in the movie. It's like,
it's just such a short scene.
But I realized that he gets over his
son's death way too fast. Now what?
We're ruining the movie for anyone
who would be interested in seeing it.
But at this point,
if you haven't seen it,
the good news is 90% of the people
listening to this are high as fuck.
And they will have forgotten everything
that you said. What about the movie?
Bobcat just says it's awesome,
but did you know it's really weird
because you don't normally,
like,
I think people see the movie and
then that gets going to be, you know,
him and his kid are always just
bashing each other and they think, oh,
at the end they're going to become
friends. And it's like, no, page 40,
I killed the fucker. Whoa. Right.
So, uh, yeah. So that's
world's greatest dad.
And then God bless America is the new
one, which is, uh, it's about a guy again.
Uh, it's about a guy who's suicidal, um,
kind of pushed over the edge by,
uh,
diagnosed with a brain tumor
and a bunch of other things.
And he's sitting at home with a gun in
his mouth and he's watching my super
sweet 16. So he decides instead of, uh,
committing suicide that he's going to,
uh,
drive 400 miles and shoot and kill
the girl from my super sweet 16,
which he does. He shoots the girl
and then her classmates like,
did you kill Chloe? And he doesn't
say anything. And she goes, awesome.
And so this young girl convinces them
that there's so many more douchebags in
the world that needs to die. So, uh,
another lighthearted movie from me
sing with a woman, Schumer. This side
throws the Tampon. Every other woman.
Do you have any family? Oh God, take this.
My name is Chloe. I live in
Virginia Beach and everyone must be,
because I'm so pretty
creepy isn't a school girl
thing a little played out.
Don't move and don't make a sound if you
want the car just taking my parents got
me the wrong one. Anyways,
that's a fucking tragedy.
Did you just kill flowy?
Awesome.
That was a fantastic start. That new.
Who else really rips my cock off to her?
Dashi and will we use rock stars?
Magic 10 and who called their tits?
The girl who was crystals.
You're aiming the bear, right? This
is the best day.
Don't let me
recording this.
Thanks for turning off your cell phone.
You're welcome.
Why have a civilization if we no
longer interested in being civilized
buddy? What's wrong? Not
a crazy people out there
who want to kill people who deserve to
die. We're going to do this or what.
I know it's not normal to want to kill,
but I am no longer normal
here. We got to take both of those
spots. Yeah. Fuck you. Fuck you.
So awesome.
Got a lot of region.
I did not.
I like to say that movie is
a very violent movie about
kindness.
That's how I describe it.
Because all frank wants his people
to act right. You know, and,
and the movie came about when I kept
seeing people acting really insane.
You know,
like at these uh,
town hall meetings where people were
shouting down people in. And you know,
I remember seeing a tea party sign.
It's kind of a popular one. It says,
we came on arm this time and I was like,
well, that's really crazy, man. You know?
That's really, yeah. And I was like, okay,
I see you're crazy and I
raise you're crazy. You know?
And that's the idea behind this
movie. It's just that it isn't, um,
a list of people who I really wish
would die. Um, I am nonviolent.
I don't believe in the death penalty
or anything, but, but, but I, you know,
it's kind of fighting fire with
fire. I, I just wanted to, you know,
really push it and not make a movie.
You know,
if you make a movie and you make fun of
these people, then they can go, oh yeah,
that's me. Ha ha ha. You know,
there's like in the new sneaky
shows up in the three stooges, so,
so even snuck his family can go, oh,
that's funny. Ha ha ha. But in my movie,
I just kill sneaky, you know? Fuck
you. You know what I mean? I'm done.
I keep wigging out, Joe. So,
no, it's, it's, so, it's,
I'm just trying to wrap my head around
it. I don't kill them for real. I mean,
I'm not just
don't feel comfortable saying and
making it, you know, we're, we really,
you know, I, my point
is, is, is what is the,
why do we have all these distractions? Do
you know what I'm saying? And, and, um,
I'm not against reality television show.
I'm not against all this stuff,
but what I'm saying is we're not really
going to come to any solutions when we
spend all of our time and name
calling and bashing each other.
Now people go, well, your movie is
very, you know, slanted to the left.
And it's like, yeah, I think
the left has lot of problems.
But I do believe the right
his way Nastier. And it
was kind of like me saying,
all right, this might be funny. Uh, a
liberal with a brain tumor and a gun.
I hate the idea of the left and the right.
I really do our thing because it doesn't
come up when they solutions. Well,
not only that, it's just this idea that
there's only two ideologies. So stupid.
Everyone's a combination
of both for the mall
to be or, but, but people choose
not to be. People just say,
I've decided that I am this ideology and
so all my decisions are made up for me
and I don't have to make my own
opinion on certain things. And, and um,
and, and, you know, uh,
an example would be like,
I agree with bill O'Reilly on the
death penalty. He's against it.
He and I can never come together because
he is too busy making his living just,
you know, a fanning flames.
He against the death penalty,
I'm sure for him it has to do with his
Catholicism. You know, that's my guess.
I don't know why,
but yet he's pro war.
Yeah. Well, yeah. Well,
I also, uh, yeah, well, Catholicism
as an adult is fascinating.
I mean, it's one thing if you're stuck
in it as a child, but as you get older,
did you grow up Catholic? Went to Catholic
school. I went to Catholic school too.
Did you go one year? Only one o one
year. It was horrible. It was ridiculous.
It fixed me. It was a very true
for me. It was very traumatic time.
My parents were getting divorced and uh,
my dad would hit my mom and there was
a lot of crazy shit and we were living
with my grandmother at the time.
That's when I started going to
Catholic school and it was so,
it was a trying time in my life and I
remember being really excited that I was
going to go to Catholic school because
I was really excited about doing the
right thing and about following the Bible
and that's how you live a happy life.
I really like frank. The reason
why this was going on in my house,
it was all fucked up because
everybody wasn't down with God.
They weren't doing the right thing.
So this one can't have a nun.
Sister Mary Josephine completely cured me.
This bitch was so evil.
She was just so mean and just
there was nothing loving about her.
There's nothing warm and friendly about
it. She was never happy. She never smiled.
She just had me convinced that it was
all horse shit. I was like, oh, okay.
There's no fucking way this lady is
involved with anything legitimate.
And he says, God, God has nothing
to do with this craziness.
What about whose idea was
it for you to go there?
Was it yours or it was my
parents. Uh, I think, you know,
it was probably one of the
better schools in the area.
It's hard to find good public schools.
It was, you know, New York, New Jersey.
Yeah. Yeah. No, I, yeah, I went
to Catholic school my whole life.
I want like a half a
year to a public school.
And it was so behind that I ended up being
the janitor and my own high school so
I could pay my tuition,
not because of any religious things,
but the fact that the education was
better there. Wow. So I, I, you know,
it's kind of funny.
We,
I didn't have any stigma about being
the janitor at the high school. I mean,
I still, oddly enough, I was like
the homecoming king too. So you,
you bought while you were going to
school there, you were also the janitor.
I was the guy that was dayglo. Why did it
have a stigma though? I was, well, I mean,
you know, it's not like being
the captain of the football team,
being the guy dragging out the
empty milk carton bags, you know?
Right. But at least you were industrious
enough to figure out how to get a job.
Yeah. No, I didn't. I mean,
I didn't think anything was embarrassing
about it was only till later on as an
adult, I would tell that story and
people would go, wow, you know?
Yeah.
There's something about being a janitor,
this particularly humbling for people.
You know, just the word janitor. You're a,
you're a guy who's essentially,
you cleaned things up. That's it.
I don't know why it didn't bother me.
I don't know why.
It just seemed like it made sense to me.
If I was a janitor,
that meant I could go to the school.
Right. Well, it's just,
it's not an impressive,
that's why it bothers
people. You know, who, uh,
wants to impress you with what they do.
You're right. But then I started doing
standup when I was like 15, 16 years old.
So when I was in highschool, Tom,
Kenny and I were doing standup. Wow.
Where were you doing it?
They get dog shows and things
like that. Open mic nights.
A Barry Crimmins who was one
of the Boston comedy guys. Uh,
he had an open mic that was in Syracuse
outside of Syracuse at the time.
We would do that every week and why our
teenagers and we had fake ids to get
into the clubs and stuff.
Holy Shit. So what, what, how
old did you have to be? Well,
18 but then when I moved
to Boston it was 19,
so I use my brother's Jimmy's
id to go do standup comedy.
So sometimes like I'd be in
Worcester and bomb and, and,
but as Jim Gulf wait,
cause I had to use my brother's ID.
Wow.
Wow. That's fucking awesome. Then
one of the coolest things about boss,
it was all those different places you
can go in and around it, you know, to,
to work so much
road work.
There was a million gigs in,
you would just pile into a car and there'd
be like four or five of you and then
you know, that's the thing you miss
in life is, is is, is the, you know,
the hell Gig and then the,
all of you,
we just laugh all the way on your
tits off on the way home. Yeah. Yeah.
So that, that goes away as you get
older, which is kind of a drag. Yeah.
That was that, that time
though, so unstable.
You can't wait for it to be over.
When did you start doing standard 88 and,
and how old were you?
21 and New York and Boston.
Yeah, I started at a stitches.
Sure. Jonathan Katz was the host,
the first, neither one on stage.
One of my last shows in Boston when I
moved out of there with it stitches,
I took all the old one or the new one,
the one that was the front of the
paradise, the old one, that's the Os one.
And I had it all filled with all this
shit from my apartment and I had a garage
sale. And up and down the street
there was signs that said garage sale,
free coffee and like I had coffee
and donuts set up when you walked in.
And then I sold the shit that I
lived with. All my shit was on stage.
Wow. Oh, that's hilarious.
Well, I never really,
I guess I've not doing
traditional standup a bunch.
When I first got started I was kind of
making fun of it and then I became the
thing I was trying to make fun of.
You know,
you were trying to make fun of it
and then you got trapped in the act.
Yeah, definitely. Yeah, definitely.
Because, because by the time I was a kid,
I mean I loved comedy when I was
a little boy, like, you know,
seven or eight years old,
I was watching George Carlin on the
Dinah shore show and I said to my mom,
what does he do for a living? And she's
like, that's what he does for a living.
And I was like, oh, that's the, yeah,
that's the best thing ever. You know,
I got to figure this out.
So by the time I was a teenager,
I was kind of snarky and stamp and I was
Kinda over the comedy that was popular
at the time. And then Steve Martin
came out and blew my mind and stuff.
So you were sort of a comedy nerd before
comedy nerds who were rowing huge, huge,
huge.
So, so that's probably why I got burnt
out by the time I was in my early twenties
you know about comedy, you know, people,
people now take it so serious that it's
kind of weird. They take it, they make it,
turn it into almost like a sports
mentality, which, you know,
I always thought in my mind,
the comedy I liked was always about
outsiders and Weirdos. You know,
it wasn't about who's the best comic
and who's the number one comic and who
sells more and who's got the most popular
podcast and Blab, Blab, Blab, you know,
it just because just because your art
is popular pretty much sometimes doesn't
mean it's very valid. You know, the two,
two things don't really connect, you know,
if something's good and popular, that's
really strange. When it does happen.
We really think so. Yeah. Yeah. But I mean
black keys. No, that's what I'm saying.
But like something like that,
there's still not like a household name.
You know my brain pretty huge.
Huge.
But they're not like if I
brought those up to my sisters,
they wouldn't know who
they are. Yeah, yeah.
I bet they would have heard their
songs. My sister, none of my,
yeah, no sparky. That's incredible.
And they're from a Hong Kong?
Well they're filling
arenas. No. Really? Yeah.
Oh they, they um, they sold out Madison
Square Garden but in like 15 minutes.
But I'm not saying that
everything that's popular is bad,
but I'm also saying it sounds
like I'm backpedaling now, but,
but you Kardashians is not really,
I know what you're saying that there's a
lot of popular shit that sucks and that
just because something's probably would,
it doesn't mean it's good. I know,
I know what you're saying. Yeah. And
I get tired of that argument. It's a,
but it's easy for me,
you know,
cause I make my movies that
only play film festivals. Well,
it's a weird go right to Vod,
you know, it's, it's what are,
what are you trying to do, you know, are
you trying to make a blip that hits the,
the, the, the, the most
amount of numbers possible?
Are you trying to like calculating your,
your attack or are you doing something
that genuinely you would love?
And it just, this is the way you do it
and you know, people are going to like it.
They're not going to like it,
but you're not like,
you're not engineering
it for financial success.
Right. But I mean, look what you're
doing. I mean, look at this on paper.
It make any sense at
all? You know, we're going to
combine, uh, mixed martial arts,
comedy and art bell.
It's kind of be popular no fucking way.
Well,
as a Canadian comedian slash cage
fighting commentator, that doesn't,
that doesn't seem to work, you
know? Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
It shouldn't work.
I think it's funny.
It's like I owe you an apology and
you don't even know it. Like I,
I had until I started listening to
the show. I had some baggage with you.
Just because, uh, and,
and why it's really unfair of me to have
it was I had a preconceived notion of
you from, from what you did on
television and, and I'm like,
if anybody should cut
anyone's in fucking slack,
it's the dude from police academy.
Do you know what I mean? Like I like,
like I had this ego thing
going, well, she's doing
standard. You know what I mean?
We're just like, oh, you're the fucking
purist. He said, oh, that's funny.
The dude from hot to trot and
you're going to be the guy from,
from fear factors to a
natural thing though.
If you have any personal anx to sorta
like look for different little weak spots.
Some of that's not cool, man. That's
not cool. But it's a natural thing.
I don't,
I didn't owe you an apology because I
never went anywhere and said that openly.
But you know what I mean?
I would completely understand it,
but for me it was like there's no way
I can not do that shows too much money.
It was to look,
I was the voice of a fruitcake last
year so I'm not about to fucking judge
anything you do, but I completely
understand people making fun of it.
I mean I make fun of it. Yeah. I
didn't make fun of my stuff too, but,
but I shouldn't judge anybody.
I went,
they asked me there was a celebrity
version of the show. Is that right?
Of what show of your
sheriff? Yeah, there's a few.
We did a bunch of them cause they asked
me to and and like I only like things
that can fuck up that I know
will make air and I really did.
The idea I came up with
it was like to put like a,
a bag of putting in my pants like brown
pudding and then wait until me being
suspended somewhere and be like,
oh I really got to get down and just
open up the bag of pudding. It just said,
but it wouldn't have made the air.
I would have fought for it.
It was really the thing I was thinking.
I was like, how can I fuck this up?
Maybe it would have made
it, you know, my commitment.
I actually wouldn't have sat there all
day with a bag full of pudding in my
pants because my commitment to fuck
things up is pretty good. I believe it.
We did it with the,
like Penn and teller did it.
A bunch of different people do it.
It was fun.
It was the food things that turned me off.
I couldn't do the most recent,
you know, we did it again recently.
We did another season of it,
like after like six years of
being wealthier and the the,
the new season people had
a drink donkey suburb.
It got leaked out on GMC.
It got leaked on Tmz,
TMZ got pictures of the glasses,
these
fucking venti Starbucks
mug full of donkey come.
Then people started protesting
and then pull the episode and so,
and then NBC pulled the episode and
they just cancel the show. They're like,
that's it. That's me. That's
my morning radio show moniker.
Donkey come doggy called
Dennis tele come and Dave.
But so, well that was it. They
all did it. It was nailed.
It
play horseshoes and this one is
who's three, three groups of twins.
One boy, two girls. So
four, four, four girls.
And one of them,
they had to decide they would play
horseshoes and one of them would be one
represent a donkey come and the other
one would represent donkey urine,
which is a was actually cows,
Yara and I think it was,
which is way the urine
is way easier to swallow.
Once you get past the fact that it's
you're in and just throw it down,
it's really not that big a deal.
It's actually you can get
away with it and they boil it.
They make sure it's sterile,
but
it's just so ridiculous.
But the other person would
have to drink the come so they,
they would play horseshoes and
everyone landed on the same thing.
They all wound up drinking 24 ounces and
you can't believe they're really going
to do it. You can't believe the real
good. Do they lay it out in the glasses?
These people drank.
I mean it's really crazy to watch
because there's essentially come all over
their face because they're not,
it's not going down. And clean.
So calm is dripping down, their cheeks
comes in their clothes. And I'm like,
for Real,
this is my job,
Disney,
this is a job.
And so I was telling them that this
ridiculous, I was like, you can't,
this is never going to air on NBC.
He's given us the green light.
They approve this episode.
They approved the, you know,
it got through standards and practices.
Like really,
really what time was that going to
be on regular time? Eight o'clock.
And so did they actually,
uh, they actually,
did they say it was not a, what
word am I looking for? Not Purified.
Sterilized.
Well, donkey come is sterile
because donkeys are hybrids.
Sea Horse come is the reason. This is
how fear factor it would work safe.
We found some people were eating something
and some other culture like Balut,
which is like this chicken embryo
or duck embryo that they love.
And the Philippines in America
is like, what the fuck is
that? Oh, it's disgusting.
And their country, it's, it's normal.
So we have to just find
something that's fucked up.
And other countries that people
eat because they're starving.
And we get people to eat it.
So in New Zealand,
some crazy assholes decided to start
selling shots of horse semen at bars.
So people get fucked up.
You have a few tequilas like
hotshot mate, let's do it all shot.
And you're doing it red bull. Yeah.
Natural red bull supposedly supposedly
gives you like a little letter.
I think the energy is just like, I just
swallowed the fucking, that's exciting.
No fucking way. Doing your heart's
beating faster. You just like Holy Shit.
It feels like drugs. So the, because
of that, the producers extrapolated.
Oh well then we'll make people drink
a big gulp of donkey jazz and they got
donkey just cause it's cheaper
chiller because it's useless.
It doesn't really make
donkeys. Oh I got, yeah,
because they're sterile cause
the shooting blanks. Yeah.
And the way they get them
is they use a cattle prod,
they stick it up to donkey's ass and it,
you know,
say rusty tromboning
next year. Yeah, exactly.
Triggers is his area blasts and then
they just gather it all up and sell it to
fear factor.
And now you said you tasted it just
because you wanted it to taste it?
I ate some,
some
wait, well, I'd say some cooked cop.
No, wait, what are you talking about?
I'm just kidding.
I'm trying to come up with a way that
it's better. I don't know man. Tom,
my aid was totally cool.
Omelet.
Yeah,
I was watching the Anthony Bourdain show
and he was at a Sushi restaurant where
they were serving com. They serve
a sperm sacks and they, they're,
they're eating this sperm sacks in the
sperm and they're like, oh, this is,
I'm good sperm.
Well, you were talking about a
sterilize. My, my wife was, uh, uh,
worked on jackass too, where
they did drink the member, the,
there's the horse berm, I believe
his Pontius, I think, but,
but there's a scene where
she's glowing pubes guys face.
If you saw that, did you
see it? No. No. Check us two
good movies give me anxiety.
She's gluing pukes out and the
guy's face as a fake beard,
but he thinks it's, he likes
his real hair or whatever. But,
um, they asked, they said,
did you, did you sterilize
this? And she's like, oh yeah,
like, are you going to
sterilize the condition? It's
like all the guys in the, uh,
you know, all the jackass guys had had
shaved their pubes and then, I mean,
there was a longer gag going on and I was,
the guy didn't know that they
gave him a Pew Beers, but, uh,
I love that, that look where
he's at. That's my gal, you
know, just, uh, but, but um,
it's funny story was, uh, after
that I was at a screening and, um,
and I know Billy crystal over the
years and uh, he comes up and goes, oh,
I just saw that jackass
too, you know. Oh my God,
that the glue and pubes on a guy's
face. And I go, Oh yeah, that's,
that's my wife. That's, that's,
that's the old girl.
He looks and he realizes,
Holy Shit,
it really is though.
It's pretty uncomfortable for
a beat there. But you know,
what are you going to do though? I
shouldn't, she's a costume designer.
But she did that, you know, cause she'll,
she'll go along with the gag. Right.
But um, but, but, but she gets
called still for people saying,
hey, will you do makeup? And
it's like I only have one makeup
look glue and pubes on the guy's face.
If you want Brian Wilson to
have a big beard, I'm your guy.
Somehow or another, she just got
attached to that. I think you do it once,
you know, just one, give
one, one cube beard.
I couldn't watch a jackass after I
watched the one clip of Johnny Knoxville
putting a blindfold on and
he lets a bowl launch, Adam,
the ball just attacks him and he goes
flying through the air and I'm like,
what the fuck? You're a movie
star Dude. What are you doing?
There's so much more to those movies other
than that you'd love and you would be,
can't watch you play
clips in her way more.
Sometimes offensive or shocking than
that. But on the Shelly, me, if we do it,
it's, you know, not for the whole
show, you know, like an hour.
I know Jack has like an hour and a half
of guys getting fucking hitting the nuts,
shotgun blast and it's like I
can't watch it all. It's too crazy.
You're too sensitive.
I might be,
you know,
you would think that I would be,
I've seen so many people get
fucked up in a real life.
Like the May commentary being that close
to the cage. You think I'd be like,
you know that that kind of stuff
wouldn't bother me anymore.
But the stuff like where I know
someone's going to get injured
still still still make,
it gives me the Heebie jeebies crashes,
anything ski crashes,
anything where your leg trip twists
backwards and slow mo and these injuries
that way I've had on him. I
know what it's like. Yeah.
It's not funny when see it once you
pee blood once. It's just not as funny.
It's not funny.
Did you have others? Japanese chef
who's a, he says he's asexual.
He's 22 years old.
He auctioned his cock
and balls off for uh,
a banquet that he was going to give.
He gave a banquet,
had his dick and balls surgically removed.
And then serve them to the patrons
for like 150,000 yen or something.
No, it wasn't. I don't really
think it was that much money. No,
it wasn't that much money. It was
like pretty cheap. Yeah. How crazy.
I'm haggling here. Um, I'm
trying to figure, well, you know,
it'd be a shame if he did all that trouble
and then they didn't taste so good.
You know what I mean? Sure. I showed
up my balls a little over done.
If Dick's tasted really good,
people beating them all the time.
There's a reason why you buy at the
pet store and they serve them to dogs.
You know, if Dick was like better
than flaming yawn, you know,
we would be eating dick, eating an
animal. But the Japanese do. I mean,
they're all lead animal. Dick's.
I know he's balls, balls.
Are they actually taste good though? Like
Rocky Mountain Oysters? No, I haven't,
but I mean, people love them.
No, I haven't had them. But
people say they love him.
You know, Rocky Mountain Oysters
apparently to people have had them,
they taste delicious.
I just don't think I ever had one.
I've never looked down at my junk.
Gets at, you know, with some parsley
maybe with some onions.
Yeah.
Just imagine if that was the best part
of the bowl to kill a whole bowl just to
get his balls.
People do it pulls away the cow
bull balls where the caviar of the,
the animal kingdom
now do you, do you uh, yeah, I w how did
we end up talking about eating balls?
Probably a fear factor
subject. Oh, sorry. My bad.
That's what it was, is the people
who drink come. That's what,
that's what killed the second season.
You mean the new season, the newest,
the second version where you bummed out
that got killed. No. Was happening. Like
I could have been doing that show
again for those six years because they,
they're doing a reboot of police academy.
Are they really going to do it?
No, they're not even going to ask
me, but I said that I go, yeah,
they're going to reboot it. Like, um,
like how they did a 21 jump street.
They're going to make it
a comedy sexy and cool.
They're going to make it a comedy.
You know,
I think I annoyed the producers so much
that they wouldn't actually have me back
and police academy. Really? Why?
Cause I was kind of a deck when we made
those movies. I mean, I wasn't like,
it wasn't like I was an asshole, but
I was also, I wasn't like going, hey,
this is really great what we're doing. Do
you know what I mean? Like I, you know,
I had a sense of humor about it. I didn't
really think, oh, this is the, you know,
the finest moments in cinema, you know?
So, uh, because of that I was, uh,
considered a pain in the ass that,
and sometimes I would say, hey,
how about at the beginning of the movie,
we have these bad guys that at the end
we could catch and the producer get
really mad. Like, oh, what are
you trying to do? You know,
they get mad at me for trying
it tried it suggest a plot.
Like I just thought
maybe if, oh, all right.
Did you try to change the
tone of the movie? No.
Make grittier this. I mean, you ever
come to them and go, listen man, listen,
do something to mix this up.
This is bullshit.
Zed wouldn't say this set
is from the streets, man.
A friend of mine is a director and a,
she's a very reasonable person.
And she was telling me some great stories
about working with actors that would
come to them and say, I think my character
should be in a bikini. And this theme,
like for no reason, like this is
a mother. She's a mother of four,
which she's going to answer
the door in a bikini, you know,
and she has a really like young haircut.
I'm thinking like shaved and this.
I was like, bitch, you're 50. [inaudible]
the fuck are you talking about?
Like they want to like
completely reworked. All of
a sudden they're creative.
You know, they take a Xanax or
whatever the fuck they're on.
Yeah, no, I would have, uh, I
remember, uh, the guy who played, uh,
pepe the clown and shakes and he would
just be for the scene just before we say
action, we've got, I think Bobcat, I'm,
I think my character
would have a Schnauzer
wowzers door. Oh yeah, sure.
Go get you a snazzier.
Let's
just do the scene. The way
it's written, the people there,
there are certain actors that
when they go on to a movie you,
you sort of assume that they're
going to rewrite things, right?
There's certain actors that
have that kind of launch,
but you kind of, you know, you hope
folks are on the same page. So,
so when they're,
when they're rewriting or changing stuff,
it's in a similar tone and it's about
the story and it's making you better,
you know?
Right. But when you have an actor
doing that, there's nothing get weird.
It's so far I've, I've
only, I think I, you know,
everybody I work with are friends of
mine and there are always people that are
on the same page,
you know,
if he can just work with a group of
your friends or on a regular basis.
Yeah. I mean I really do think
that like people thought like,
oh you work with Robin Williams, you know,
that he was going to be spinning out,
you know, doing his Improv's and
stuff. And it was more like, you know,
he knew this guy and he ad libs or any
changes were really valid. You know,
they were his suggestions. You know,
I think people confuse Robbins standup
with his acting. Yeah. And you know,
Robin's interesting,
he takes acting really serious.
Like I think he actually thinks of
himself as an actor first, you know,
cause he went to Julliard and stuff like
that. You know, he's a, he's a, he's a,
he's one of the best actors in the
world. I agree. I think as an actor,
I think he's amazing.
I think,
I think he's better as an
actor than even as a standup.
I think he's just incredible. I
think photo booth movie, what?
It was at one hour photo.
Yeah, he's a, he's incredible.
He's, you should check out
the movie. He and I made,
it's a, he's, you know,
it was funny cause like before we
started to work on it, I was like,
is he going to listen to me? You know, and
I'm not going to say let's do this one.
Just do kind of mellow and uh,
oh is he going to say you
were in hot to try it?
And I have an Oscar so we're going
to do it my way. But that's not,
he never pulled any shit like
that. He was, uh, he was, you know,
we hope to keep Megan movies.
We'll probably do another movie together.
Do you feel free from police academy?
No. I mean, I know when I
die the, there'll be a photo
of me in a police uniform.
You know what I mean?
There's no way.
There's no way around it, but you
know, if people remember me at all,
it'll be that way. Yeah. Did you
ever have regrets? Um, yeah, always.
You know, but, but I don't, I
don't, it just took me almost,
it's taken me almost, you know, 25,
30 years to get where I am now and
now I make these small little movies.
I do stand up, so, you know,
to pay my rent and, uh,
I'm really happy.
So all the things that I would file
under regrets actually helped me get to
where I am.
You know,
when you're doing stand up,
do you ever,
are you doing it as you,
are you doing?
No, it's me now. I think. I'm like, yeah,
and I think like if I did do the
persona and some of the markets,
it would be more helpful
because a lot of the country,
it still is the eighties you know
what I mean? You know, if you say,
if you go to Kansas and they go,
oh,
the guy from police academy
and he's come in and,
but he's not going to do that voice.
Oh really?
Why do I want to go see that? He's
going to tell funny stories, you know?
But I think if it's like a poisons come
in and they're not doing every roses.
Yeah. So, uh, but you know,
it was a decision I had to make just
because I was back on the road and I was
like,
why do I hate the road?
And I thought it was because I hated the
wacky morning teams in the shyster club
owners and the shitty opening
acts. Sorry Brian. [inaudible].
No, no. I just,
I haven't even seen your standard. Right.
It was right there. It was just like, no,
but,
but I realized I just hated doing this
persona that I had no connection to
anymore. You know, just because of
people's obligated. People were, you know,
wanted to see it. Did you drop it and
then go back to the same club like that?
You were there a year before and
they were like, Hey, what the fuck?
There's certain clubs.
I think definitely because you know,
what happens eventually is it, I think
it did affect my ticket sales, you know,
so there's a certain rooms I don't
work anymore, but, but you know,
I have to do what so I can hit
the pillow at night and feel okay.
Yeah.
Well it's,
and it's also the idea that you could
only be funny as our character. Silly.
You know what I mean? But
here's the thing, it's funny,
it's like back in the day on my early HBO
specials, there was material, you know,
I was doing stuff about the Iran contra
hearings and things like that in my act,
you know, eh, but, but
because of my persona,
people didn't understand that there was
anything going on in my act, you know?
So it never bothered me because I thought
it was a great way I could sneak my
message in. But in hindsight,
um, you know, sometimes,
sometimes I'll read something snarky
when I'm Ego surfing on the web and it'll
be like the guy for police,
you can, we believe blah,
blah, blah. And I'm like, gone,
dude. You watch those movies.
That's the only reason you're
mad, you know, I didn't,
you know what I mean? So, so
whatever, you know, I don't,
I don't let too much of it bothered me
because I'm so much into my own thing.
And, and the other thing is
funny is, is I'm not really
nostalgic, you know, I mean,
I,
I'm really always onto the next project.
I'm always riding after world's greatest
dad. I wrote five screenplays, you know,
so, and, uh, God bless
America is just one of them.
Should I just keep writing all the time?
Windy city.
He's one of my favorite movies.
And there was some talk for your time
too, to bring a second one around. Uh,
and I know there's a lot of fans of
like Perry and dawn and all that,
and they even have a pretty
successful podcast. Did you,
did you enjoy making this movie? Did you
ever think about making a s, you know,
a second one or,
um, only if, uh, uh, only if, uh,
if Perry was on board.
I think I, uh, you know,
obviously you can't do it
without him, but, but I, uh, the,
the idea doing another one, you know,
maybe I don't rule it out, you know,
it is, I do think it's, it's, uh, it's,
it's probably the funniest thing
I've ever been involved in. Yeah,
that's for sure. It had to.
Yeah. That's such a great cast.
Did you have anything, any of the,
are these a lot of your friends?
Like Dang Coco was in it. Did you
just do comedy standup with no, the,
it's a combination of
a bunch of different,
a bunch of different comedians
and their friends and, and uh,
and actors and stuff.
Rolling Polanski film that was
dramatic to dramatic people.
People don't know.
Can you explain the whole story behind
windy city heat or is that too much of a
giveaway giveaway?
I think people should just watch it.
I know people watch it and they
think it's fake. Uh, that's,
that's fine. You know, I don't argue it.
Kimmel doesn't argue that
either. You know, so, you know,
people just have to explore it on their
own. But I do know that I think it is, uh,
it's clearly, I think the funniest thing
I've been involved in. Really? Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah. A lot of people don't
know this is Perry on the left
and it's Don Berenson Moodle. Okay guys,
thanks a lot. I just call my agent,
you know, can make a
decision. Thanks. Okay. Hey,
Carson Daly. All right.
Yeah. Hi, I'm Don Burris.
Everyone's in on the joke.
Parents on the fanny pack in
the jackets were in the hat. Oh,
I'm looking at,
I'm looking at myself or somebody
that wants to be me and I'm saying,
and I'm thinking to my head,
this is somebody that needs
his ass kicked bad, real bad.
I
think he got the role.
They want to see one another guy,
some scary. So scary. Fairly.
Is that what you're calling
me, Perry Perry, I'm stolen.
Stolen.
Listen you later.
Did you ever worry at any point in time
that you're dealing with a crazy person
when you were doing this movie?
Got Embarrassed?
Yeah. I worry about that every
time I deal with that bear.
I love Don Baer. Yeah, I, uh,
I get to the other guy is a, is
a, is a great actor actually. But,
um, uh, besides being
a funny guy, um, I, uh,
uh, yeah, yes. Yeah, of course.
I mean, it's, it's, it's, it's,
it's really on the edge, man. I mean,
it was a really strange and uncomfortable
and scary movie to make. I mean,
it was really fucking weird.
Do you feel bad at all? No,
because Perry gets what
he wants and what's he,
what's he want more than anything is fame,
you know? Yeah. Right. But he's crazy.
Nice nights. No, I mean, you know,
as opposed to other comedians.
Yeah.
Let me tell you a little about stone.
He's a, uh, he's a hard drinking,
hard talking,
hard live in tough guy.
And we've seen a lot of
people for this role.
We saw Kendall Feeney Liotta and a Whoa,
pat.
We actually narrowed down the field,
uh,
to yourself and one other actor who we
just saw who was just walked out of here.
He was quite, uh, quite good. Carson
is a joke.
That's your painting
can do this role of me.
That's great. Wow. He's
crazy though. Are you ready?
And
Perry,
I, I'm sorry, a Lotta Lotta
Draegers. They say action.
I just said, and thank you.
So when you're hearing me say,
and you go,
and
my name is stone,
stone fury,
let him
very seriously.
I'm sorry. I apologize. I know
you're excited guys. We're just,
we're just getting into this key.
Please. Just step out. Okay. Carrie,
you get these guys evacuated
from this building.
They're gone next. I like, I
like what you were on that.
Okay. This is not gonna
make any sense. Yeah.
This is not for me right now.
People are not in a form is not making
any sense. I'm going to have to give,
can I give away a little bit of
us going ahead? The Guy Perry the,
they have him convinced that he's a star.
They make a movie around him and he's
just a crazy guy and he's crazy enough to
actually believe that he really is like
a movie star. He's The star of a movie.
[inaudible] city heat.
And so they, you basically
shoot a movie with him
and winked a crazy guy.
Everybody. Everybody. Yeah.
Everybody's in on the joke that he's
this movie star and Dog Barris tries to
ruin. Like, I mean Don Barrett's is pretty
much tortures him like he does well,
it's brilliant. The thing,
it's really brilliant.
Once you realized that this guy does not
know and then you realize what a crazy
fucking must be to let this go this
deep without like stepping back once and
going, hey wait a minute,
what the fuck's going on here?
Did you, I mean if
there's giant, you know,
trucks out front and everybody and you
have your parking spot and you'd drive
onto the lot and well he had to sign off
on those and know in the women love you
and he loves this movie.
But I mean when you see the movie,
it's really interesting because
immediately, you know, making demands and,
and bossing bossing his intern
around and so fascinating.
It's a, it's a, it's a onion that
never stopped peeling away. Seriously.
You know,
cause I showed it recently at all Lana
and people had questions and they said,
you know, that is Perry real. And
so I just called him on the phone.
It's like he's off and running.
You know,
what does Perry do to take care of
himself these days? I, you know, he,
he w he is a,
a sag extra,
he does show up in movies as a sag extra.
And for the longest time he worked in
his family's print shop that I heard
recently.
100.
So yeah,
I didn't know when he city
it's a, it, it's like I said, it's,
it's really a fascinating movie.
I mean, I, I can't say it's not
my baby because don and, and,
and mall and, and, uh,
Jimmy Kimmel and all these folks have
been doing this for about 11 years before
I got involved in directed this.
They had been doing this with the same
guy for years and they still do it today
on the big three podcasts
that Don Barris does.
So he's still thinks he's a movie star.
Oh yeah. They, they, uh, they actually,
it's even gotten crazier
now because if you're,
especially if you're a local La guy,
they have like people like leads mattress,
that guy goes,
we won't be beat.
He's now like a sponsor and
he's just a crazy person.
So you have this guy that you're used
to on the match or sky from the TV
commercials here now is somehow
part of this show and it's just,
it's amazing. It's amazing. You know,
Perry and you go, well Perry, here's
refrigerator Perry. And it really is him.
So I mean, you know, all these things
kind of made it easier. So when you say,
and here's our still photographer,
Ansell Adams, hello, Mr. Adams.
You know what I mean?
So why wouldn't it be ancillary
if I just met the real refrigerator?
Perry dude,
I can't figure it out.
I used to have backaches when I was
making the movie going. I was like,
this isn't same. You know what? You know,
I started thinking people were
filming me when I was peeing.
You started getting
paranoid and really crazy.
No sense of guilt whatsoever for
not now.
Not now,
but I know that he's very happy with
the outcome. When all said and done,
he's happy that again, it gave them a lot
of attention. Yeah, it still does. Right?
He got paid. He got paid very well when
he did it and stuff. So, you know, and um,
but, uh, you know what,
what's, I don't know, you know,
I,
Ooh, this is for the rest of my life.
I love it. I hope there's more bearish.
Never had a problem fucking clown when
the guy, oh, he's still, you know,
bears has his hand in like a million
different pots and now he does the Ding
Dong show.
We had podcast here the other day where
we had a live Ding Dong show and it was
the craziest thing I've ever seen
in my life. I was half what's alive,
Ding Dong show. He, it was dawn Barris,
a Iko Tanaka Jane, and they brought,
uh, uh, two other Ding Dong years,
schizophrenia surfer who's
a schizophrenia. We'd guy,
he's like smoking weed and,
and then you have a Tennessee I think
is his name and who's also from Tim and
Eric and Andy. They just pretty much had
a show. And it was the craziest thing.
I've, if you watch it, it's, it's,
it's like watching a train wreck that
you can't look away. It's amazing. Uh,
but yeah, it will be up on
death squad soon, but a heat,
don ha does the shit he does. You
know, like the Ding Dong show,
he has the big three.
He also has a, his band,
which is an air guitar band where he
has this whole band where people are
playing fake instruments that he does
almost every single night at the comedy
store. This guy. And he does open
up for Kimmel every single day.
Every single day. He, you
know, or whenever Kimmel has
it, she has the warm up here,
just the warm up. He is the most busy.
Don is a workaholic and that guy is,
you know,
fucking working every single day.
This is really good at tricking crazy
people. Yeah. It's going to be excellent.
I was going to be here Friday
for the desk would show Friday.
So tickets are available now.
I
Don Don barristers a motherfucker.
He's another one of those guys where I
never quite understood why he never got,
you know,
more recognition. Yeah. He's
a funny dude. But you know,
you're implying that show business
based on merit and talent and stuff.
I always hoped that someone
finds the good ones.
But I think that's a lot of,
it has to be a tenacity and your
ability to compromise. You know,
I think, I think those are the things
that really rewarded in show business.
Tenacity for sure.
The ability to compromise.
You mean do things you
don't really enjoy doing
to further your career?
Yeah. That can help
get help that money is, money is the
most important thing. Get some money,
then you don't have to worry
anymore. But do you, uh,
do you find money does make
you happy? No. No it does not.
But it definitely takes away the unhappy
feeling of being broke so it doesn't
make you happy. Yeah. And then, and
then, you know, my thing would be,
you know, do things for money
and then, and then below it
because it's so self destructive.
Yeah. So now I'm much happier, uh,
trying to kind of live a life that's way,
way smaller.
So I know some of my nuts not as big
think to not have to think about shit like
that. And then money, Mo problems. Well,
there's that to a certain
extent too, you know? But I,
I remember very clearly when I was young
when I first started making some money
doing stand up, like, like not having
to worry about paying my bills anymore.
I remember that feeling,
you know,
it was really when I got a development
deal from based on stand up for some
Disney thing and they gave me like a
chunk of money and I remember at, wow,
there's some money in the bank right now
I don't have to worry about now I can
stop thinking about my bills for a while.
Like it was a huge like,
well wait, what was the first thing
you bought? Like without like,
you know what I mean?
Like going
like, you know, like Jethro Bodine.
Like what was the first thing that you
just pointed at and said it's like a
massage chair. Hold those massage
chairs. Yeah, those are awesome.
Like a Barca lounger. They
had a, yeah, yeah, exactly.
Yeah. Yeah. Really good.
The sharper image. Yeah.
Threw it away. No, no. I still have them.
Actually the first things I got when I
got some money when I first came out to
California and I was on a sitcom. That
was the first thing. I got massage too.
So cool.
I remember sitting in one of them at a
mall and going, this is the most amazing,
the rich people live rollers.
Tappers it goes
down your bag. It's really pretty
awesome. Some day I'm going to be famous.
I'm going to get what I mean. The new
ones are even better than new ones.
They were in your arms go into cases and
it massages your arms and your legs and
massages your legs.
Yeah, it's really crazy
and grabs it. Yeah. You just have
to hope it doesn't go haywire.
Fuck [inaudible] earthquake happens.
Do you want to get the fuck out of there
and it's Howard crap with the flashlight
we met.
We've actually got completely full circle.
While you're screaming for help,
you think I have to throw this flashlight.
It's far away with possible so it
seems like we're not connected.
I'm going to go out.
It's throw it down the hallway.
I think that's the way to go out though.
I know people are always talking about
being afraid to be found that way. I say,
you know, whatever,
you're dead. It's over.
It's an opportunity for people to
make fun. Put a rubber fist in my ass.
You know? Even she even in favor of
faking it. Yeah. Oh, that's beautiful.
You're a team player.
Always. Always. Again,
I know the distance for the laugh.
You know what you gotta do. You know?
I would only hope someone with a sense
of humor, which fine me. Well, you know,
there was that video of the guy
who got fucked to death by a horse.
You've seen the video? I
haven't watched it, but I know
the movie zoo. Yes, exactly.
I heard you talking about, I was at
Sundance when that movie was there. Yeah.
After that guy dying that way and
that video being on the Internet,
that guy gave like a
huge amount of people,
a big burst of positive energy.
I don't watch it. I don't want
to be positive. I laugh, man.
This fucking something funny.
This is a guy and there's a guy helping
the Horse Dick in his ass and it's
ridiculous.
It's one of the most ridiculous trends.
How do you make that car go?
Hey, I want to fuck a horse,
but I'm going to need a little,
how can I help you? Well,
you're going to have to put the
Horse Dick in my ass. All right.
What time we had done it many, many
times is not good. I have a mini panic.
They did it. Yeah, they
actually to Seattle just
to, to do that. I think it's weird
that you can't watch jackass,
but you can watch that. That's quick.
It's really quick. So it's about the time,
you know, it's about, I mean I'm
sitting down watching jackass.
So committing to an hour and a half of,
you know,
soccer kicks to the balls and the
horses running over people and ah,
get anxiety.
But a quick,
have a quick clip of a dude getting
raped to death by a stallion.
Fuck that.
Just first of all, if there's a guy
who's out there willing to do that,
you need to know. I just think you need
to know to put it in your computer,
Bank of human behavior.
This is the full spectrum.
You should know the full spectrum.
We shouldn't be shocked by it.
That's only the spanx from when they had
a camera handy. True. You know, I mean,
well they had a hundred hours of footage.
Well this is what happened.
The guy bled out. They drive
him to the, to the hospital.
The police said your friend's dad to
fuck what's up with all the hay and blood
around his asshole.
And then they confessed.
And so they had to explain what happened.
And on a technicality,
it wasn't really illegal because
they were living in Washington state.
And until this movie zoo came out,
when the movies who came out,
they changed the law.
That was what the actual take mean.
They had to have a fucking movie written
about the fact that people were moving
to their states specifically so
they can get fucked by animals.
So his death was a romantic
spat. It was a, uh,
a blip of laughter and happy that I should
smile at the feeling of if your life
is fucked up and you're,
you know,
credit card debt and you don't know what
the fuck you want to do with yourself
and somebody sends you a clip of a guy
getting fucked to death by a horse,
put it all in perspective. Do you go
before, that's what floats your boat.
It's not floating anybody's boat.
What it is is oh, W as watching it,
I'm talking about the guy who's doing it.
Like how do you get to that point? Well,
here's the other thing.
He also has piercings all over his
balls and this is why the related,
they think that people who get a lot of
like genital piercings and things along
those lines may be suffering,
not just from trauma,
childhood trauma,
which most likely there some of that too.
And sexual trauma usually,
but also that they might have a disorder
that makes it very difficult for them
to feel pain like a normal person.
So they try to get pain, right?
So they do things like pierce themselves
in very sensitive areas and you know,
a thing,
things along those lines.
And that might also be connected to
the idea of letting a horse fuck you.
It's like, you know what I mean? Like
they need like an extreme sensation.
They have a need for extreme sensation.
And that makes sense. That makes sense to,
to me,
if you just think about the variations
in behavior and people that you've met,
well I could see it being completely
haywire and being like that. You know,
that may ball piercings needs a horse
dick in his ass. It's this the spectrum.
And the guy was like,
the guy was like an architect man.
He's like a professional dude.
They probably have a lot of
qualities that are all together,
you know, like, like, or like when
they get married, you know, he,
the guy takes on the woman's last name
or something like that. Those same,
same kind of group of people
guessing that is some weak shit.
Look guys,
it takes on the woman's
now and that is some weeks.
It's a battle you're already
losing. Yeah, I saw, uh, some,
some reality show. Was it,
some guy did that recently?
I can't remember. Well, I
knew a dude who, uh, the,
the hyphen hyphen names or even worse
if he killed combine or you combine both
of your last name and last name.
Well that's, you know, that's our
mayor. You know, our
mayor in a, in California.
What the fuck is his name? Uh, uh,
go egg will Arlo wa I don't know
what the fuck is. His name doesn't,
it doesn't even matter does it? That's
ridiculous. But it doesn't matter what it,
his name is. His name was like,
okay, no, I have to pull it up.
His name was not a Latino name. And he
combined his name and his wife's name.
It became a Latino name. They
got divorced. He kept that.
What's ridiculous?
See,
that's the kind of person that gets fucked
in the ass by horse. Uh, did you ever,
I know Steve Martin, you said that
was one of your influences, uh,
for Standup, I guess. Uh, so, so was mine.
Uh, did you ever get to meet Steve Martin?
Did you have any cool Steve Martin
story? I mean, I guess, you know,
now if I see him, we, we will be friendly.
But the first time I met him I was
doing Letterman and, and he said, uh,
he goes,
Hi Howie.
He thought I was how I met. Oh. And
how he's a nice guy and everything,
but I felt like a Ming vase that got hit
with a ball peen hammer. And he's like,
Oh, I'm not, how are you man, don't.
Right. That's hilarious. Nice to meet you,
mark. No, I didn't say that back. So
you just played the role as Holly?
Actually,
I put a rubber glove on
Los Angeles. His name is Tony
Vlr. That's his real name.
He calls himself Antonio Villaraigosa.
Yes.
He completely Latino the fuck out
of his name. He combined his name,
but his wife's name.
And then when they got divorced he
just kept riding the Latino bull three
ticketless. That's cute.
That shouldn't be legal.
That seems like, that
seems like a, a hoax. What?
You shouldn't be able to just
change your name and, and, and, oh,
you mean for voters? Well, it just
seems like it's a, it seems unethical.
I know a couple of girls,
I want to change their names,
especially if it's your fucking former
wives name man. That's ridiculous.
Well I think it's weird when you get a
divorce and then the person's still keeps
the name that
it's less confusing,
but you know, well they
could do it forever to, they
can keep that shit forever.
Once they changed their name,
they just thinking
they can just rock it forever. It
should expire. Should totally expired.
It doesn't make any sense.
How could you be married for a year and
that woman becomes how many years you
were living with that person is how
long they could have your name. Oh yeah,
I was that. That's a good one. Yeah. Cause
you can hear you then. That's ridiculous.
It should be half the time. Get over it.
They shouldn't be. Yeah. I think, uh,
you know,
well for me alimony is crazy because
I'll be paying it until my ex wife passes
away or gets remarried. Yeah. Why? Yeah.
How's that work? Well, how
will you respond to me? Look
at me. I'm looking at it.
She had a fuck this. No, I don't know.
I mean, I think it's, uh, it's no,
but that sounds bizarre that people can
never get their life together without
you. Let's say you tainted,
she can't make a living.
There's no way it's impossible. I'm going
to hold up to Bob's Grad school after,
but it seems like,
you know,
like why should you be responsible
for her for the rest of your life?
More than other adult. Yeah. It's so
weird. Childish Law. Yeah. It's terrible,
but it's foolish, you know?
But, but when you get married,
you know, that's, you know,
you don't expect that you're going
to get divorced. So, you know,
you're not thinking about that. I mean,
I guess if you did, you were kind of,
I guess that would be healthier,
but it's also kind of a pessimistic
way to enter a relationship.
Laws is so preposterous.
It's just so ridiculous.
You should have to pay for
her forever. Like why, why,
why it did you take from her
her ability to make a living?
Did you take from her her ability to take
care of herself? Of course you didn't.
No, but I think it's, it's, it,
it stems from a very old timey
kind of thing. Like, you know,
when the woman stayed at home and,
and w weren't allowed to be professional
and get a job and stuff like that.
Yeah. It's, it's weird how many
shit laws like that are in place.
It's like whenever there's a situation
where someone can get fucked it,
you know,
and,
and you do see it like in the case of
divorces in like something like your case
where you have to pay someone for that
many years. It is very, very frustrating.
It's very frustrating to watch.
It's very frustrating to see
something that's not logical.
Well it's not logical, but you know, it's
like the old street joke, uh, you know,
why his divorce expensive.
Cause it's worth, it
doesn't fuck with your head that
you have to send alimony sometimes.
Sometimes when I'm like, you know, when I,
when I booked the gathering of the
Juggalos Oh did you do that? Sure. Yeah.
It's part of the alimony. He had to go to
training. I don't know. It's coming up.
You have your spinning training, you
could probably dodge still. Yeah, I, yeah,
I'll go back to the serpentine
serpentine. Holy Shit. Just sweet gig.
Wow.
And you think about that when you,
when you get those gigs.
Yeah. When you get a call
like that and you know,
and actually when I got the call
for the gathering of the Juggalos,
I didn't think of it as in money gig.
I was like, yeah, all right, I'm there.
Whatever man, this is going to be
awesome. That's gonna be crazy.
Why are you smiling at me again? It's
hilarious. I like taking gigs that,
that other people when I do enjoy that
for some reason, I don't know why.
Did you take time off of dual stand up?
Yeah,
I did for years when I was
directing the Kimmel show.
How much time did you take her off?
It was then.
It was probably about three years.
Maybe like about five altogether.
What drew you back in? It was, it was,
you know, going back and making a living.
Doing it was, was what, what drew
me back in. Yeah. I mean, you know,
I don't like putting that
out there. It's like, hey,
and now coming to the stage a guy, he
was only here to make money. It's bobcat.
Goldthwait phoning it in.
Did you feel like you're falling in
or when you actually just went on?
When I got back I tried to do comedy.
Yeah.
I mean I have a blue collar background,
so my whole thing is actually trying
to go out and do a show for people.
You know? I mean it sounds corny and
stuff, but if you're there to see me,
I've tried to work really hard.
Now if I ended up being on
a bill when other comics,
then I don't mind screwing around.
Do you know what I mean?
Like at a comic relief when I would
dress up as Christ and do magic tricks,
you know, water to wine, wine to water,
tap the deck and back to rice again.
You know, and I was the amazing
Christ out and stuff. But I mean that,
that's an example of me just having fun.
But, but if you come out to see my show,
I am going to work really
hard. I mean, you know,
you don't want to disappoint people
that actually paid to see you.
I, yeah, I feel the exact same way.
And I know what you're saying about it
sounds kind of Corny, but it's, it's,
it's admirable, you know? I
mean, that's the relationship.
That's how it's supposed to be there.
They're paying,
you want to do the best fucking
possible job you can to just,
the fact that you're asking people to
pay to hear you talk sounds ridiculous.
You've got to work really hard.
You worked really hard. But you
know, uh, my friend John Evans,
and I always say this is kind of
true, unfortunately in comedy, you're,
you're trying to keep the dumbest
person in the room occupied.
You know what I'm saying? And
that's why like when, you know,
I do like making these small
indie movies because you know,
the dumbest person goes to battleship.
You know what I mean?
Do you think that in this day in age
that that has to be the case though?
No, I think now that's why. That's
what's exciting about podcast.
That's what's exciting about, you know,
people are talking to their audience.
I think it's, it's great. Like some
people go, I think that, well, you know,
alternative comics are comics that just
performed for their podcast crowds.
You know, that's copping
out. That's, you know,
it's harder just to be a bar comic and
it's like, well what's the big deal?
Being in a bar comic, you know, making
every crowd again now if you can.
I never heard that argument.
That's hilarious argument.
If you make every crowd,
if can perform for
every crowd and kill, I guarantee
your act is about absolutely nothing.
Do you know what I'm saying?
I guarantee you there's some
puppets involved or something.
There's nothing wrong with finding
a crowd in the idea that you know,
you find your own crowd that's going to
soften you up. No Way. It's preposterous.
No, because that's like, if anybody,
interesting you ever watched
when they found their own crowd,
that's when they took off,
you know,
like prior or Bill Hicks
even or you know what I mean?
People who had something to say.
Yeah. Once you have people that they're
expecting you to be, you, then you're,
you're fine. You don't have
to, everybody's got their
own sense of humor, man.
And to to do so just have a show that
says comedy is like just having a show
that says music.
No,
not knowing if it's going to be Barry
Manilow or guns and roses or what the fuck
is going to be, you know? Yeah, exactly.
It's just weird that comedy is so,
it's so generic, you know, and it's
term. Well, it's supposed to be.
Yeah, but it's in its actual application
though, it's very, it's very, very,
and it's very personal. You know the idea
that like, well, I didn't like your act,
and then it's like, Whoa, you
know, I don't want to be rude,
but I probably wasn't
trying to entertain you.
That Holtzman gathered I was selling.
He was one of the funniest guys ever
that people don't know if I brought some
friends, the comedy store, and
they said, you were so funny, lol,
but I have to tell you that one guy,
oh my God,
he needs to give it up is just not funny.
It's so mean.
Exclamation point.
You went work.
I go,
okay.
Everybody's different when that twilight
lady sells a lot of fucking books, man.
Yeah, that's true. People like it,
you know, but to you or I, it's shit.
Would we want to read it? No. Would we
be angry if you wanted to talk about it?
Probably,
but it doesn't mean it shouldn't exist.
Well, that's the thing. It's like in the
new movie, you know, God bless America,
people go, well, this character, she just
turned off the TV and it's like, well,
if you try to avoid this stuff,
you can move. You would suck.
Turn the TV off and he doesn't
kill anyone. He says, ah,
I'm going to go read a book.
Go fucking movie one kid. Well,
that's the other thing.
People are going,
how could I do the Q and a and people
are going, they don't get caught, man.
They'd get caught. It's
a movie man. You know,
you know I wasn't going to have a scene
where I kept cutting back to Harvey
Keitel in front of a map going,
I got to get inside their brain,
kind of figure out where
they're going to hit next.
That would be funny if you did
do that though. Just a random,
that's the end of the movie.
To be continued.dot dot.
Kaytel looking down at a
map one day in the desert.
They seem to be killing reality stars.
Someone quick get over to
the Kardashians house asap.
I figured it out. That's
the pattern. What,
what does it look to you
to have grown up in an era with no
internet to grown up in an
error with uh, you know, doing,
stand up as a teenager with all these
like real comics to seeing shit like
reality stars to seeing Shit like the
Kardashians and Jersey shore housewives of
this, of that. What is that?
Is it freak you out at all?
Does it worry you about the, the course of
our culture? Well, I think, yeah, I mean,
uh, you know, it is what, why do,
what's the point of these shows?
What's, why are we fascinated? What, why,
why is it, you know, it's the coliseum,
you know, that's what we're doing
now. We're taking our week and,
and our dumbest and we're
making entertainment out of
them. You know, like Terry,
it was that bad. I said, well,
I mean, you know, maybe a,
and maybe you are what you hate. I mean,
maybe that's why I made the new movie,
you know, uh, Kimmel's that bad actually.
He said that frank would shoot
the people who made Wendy's,
but I think, uh, you know, uh,
I don't get as angry about them,
their success and stuff.
I'm more angry at our
appetite for the distraction.
Do you have an appetite for it?
I used to and I actually just like the
character about about four or five years
ago, I said, I'm out. You know, I'm
not watching anymore this stuff.
What were you watching?
I would,
I would watch the freak
show part of American idol.
And then I started feeling really
guilty. I was like, I'm out, man.
I'm out.
Yeah.
That was what was good about it.
What was good about it was
that it was terrible. And
then I said, I can't do this.
I go, I the, the, the, the,
you know, the little ting,
it takes out of my soul. I'm out.
Can you watch people bomb? Yeah.
I have no problem watching. Doesn't
bother you at all. It feels right.
Yeah.
I like watching people watching
shit is probably one of the few things
that entertains me in a comedy club. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Wow. I have no compassion
for them. You know? I think it's great.
I love to watch someone eat shit.
Why is that? Because, because it,
cause here's the thing,
it's like,
here's something at one point that I
took really serious and you're trying to
think that it's just easy or are
you just thinking that is bombing?
There's have to be thinking again.
Again,
like a talented comedian bombing is
hilarious. You know what I mean? Like,
you know,
oh my God,
Kevin Meeney bombing is the funniest
fucking thing on the planet. You know,
I went to that and he's very animated.
Very funny guy. Best Kevin Meeney bombing.
I don't care about jokes. No,
go over. That's the Kevin me,
that's not even real bombing. He's
singing. He's telling a joyous time.
Real bombing is not knowing what's
coming out next. So what's next?
And you just eat it up there.
You can't remember your material and your
fucking mouth is dry bricks of shit or
tumbling out of your mouth. He tried
to pass him off as gold to the crowd.
It sounded like an Eminem Song,
man.
Over hyping every fucking
premise cause you're gonna.
This is the one that's going to turn
this set around. I'm telling you,
if you threw some beats to that Jag,
he just went on s and m and m's song.
I feel it. I feel it. You
know I'm from the street.
I'm from the streets now from every,
it's an everybody for one fucking
street who was from the prairie.
I'm from the colder sack motherfucker.
I uh,
I'm from such a New York bitch.
You were around when you,
you saw America pre and post crack too.
That's something people in their late
forties have seen something that most
people in this country
didn't know existed.
There was a pre and post crack period
and a lot of people aren't aware of that.
Like crime and cities and things.
Accelerated
drove salary. Yeah. And that was about the
same time that we dumped, uh, you know,
our mentally ill people out on the street.
It was the Reagan years. Yeah, yeah.
Do you remember when
Reagan was like the enemy?
Do you remember when everybody hated
Reagan? Now Obama's quoting him and stuff,
it's so weird. But Reagan,
you know, uh, you know,
I remember like when they dump the uh,
uh,
mentally ill and homeless folks on
the street, it was like a switch.
It wasn't like,
it was almost like instantaneous,
like totally different and
how, you know, so that's like,
you know, when people say, you know,
the way we treat the mentally ill
and our country, you know, it is,
we just choose to ignore them,
put them in movies
or you're not going to let
it go. All right. Yeah.
Because I've had people say
because of the new movie,
you know,
what if somebody saw and then went out
and killed people and you know I have two
responses to that.
One is if you could make people
killers by making movies,
the military would make more films.
And the other is if we're going to
start banning violent works of fiction,
we need to start with the Bible.
Those are my two bear.
Good. Very good one.
Yeah, it's ridiculous.
There are the idea that you can't
have violent fictions. It's fun.
Fiction is great and it's actually been
proven to instead of give people the
need to go and commit crime and
actually satiates our crowd just like,
like porn does for people porn,
like people that have access
to porn or less likely to rape.
It's like statistics that showed us.
But the thing is is
is if you, with the killers, it's when,
when people do do a Columbine and stuff,
it's easier to blame
Marilyn Manson then to look.
Those kids weren't even Marilyn
Manson fans. First of all,
it's just like some witch hunt and,
and the thing is is
whenever someone does snap,
there's always like Gabby Giffords.
You know, when someone's snaps,
that kid gave a ton of signs. It
didn't happen one day. He, you know,
the teachers didn't want to show up
when he was in his class and they have
security. So we have like
a whole ostrich, you know,
we stick our head in the
sand when someone's crazy
and just hope that they don't
snap instead of if you're on the left, you
want them to get help. If you're right,
let's say you want them to carceration
but the way we treat people who are
dangerous now with absolutely having no
policies at all is way more dangerous
than my goddamn movie.
So get off
Dick. Yeah, I hear you.
And those Columbine kids,
weren't they on antidepressants
or they're on something?
I don't know. I mean
I, I don't, I know that
them by antidepressants,
it's probably probably the
hottest kind of drug right now.
Call Him Barney antidepressants is,
imagine,
imagine living that town and that town
is forever attached to the fuck it is the
Columbine. Yeah. You could
say, don't go all call him,
buy it on. Right, right, right,
right. That's that school. That's
crazy. I mean that's that, uh, that,
that neighborhood forever attached to a,
yeah. They run into the presence. Yeah.
Well they say that like there's certain
modes of antidepressants that aren't
good for teens. Obviously that might be
a case. There's a lot of people, I mean,
the antidepressant thing is a very,
it's,
it's not an exact sort of a methodology.
They give him the,
on the gold, try this, tell us
how you feel and you could say,
I feel great and he's like, good,
we're going to keep you at this dose.
You can say, um, I'm just
not feeling enough. Okay.
We're going to crank up your dose.
Like think it's all based on you saying,
you know, how, how are we dealing
with this medication? This one sucks.
We're going to try something new.
I've had friends that have gone through
the three or four different medications
that tells me that there's
a lot of my exact, yeah. Or,
or friends who suddenly the personalities
gone, which is weird. Too Spooky.
That's like, yeah. I've seen people
like everything becomes okay. Okay.
You know, just started, they stop Karen.
They just doesn't, whatever they're on,
whatever. Which one it is to shuts
it all off. It's okay. Right now,
my camp peeps larue is on some heavy
shit. The cat is on. Yeah, she's a,
hopefully she'll be off of it soon,
but yeah, she's a little zonked out.
What is she on? I don't know.
Whatever we're given her.
Every once in a while she will find
them in the corner. She like, doesn't,
she spits him out. She's like,
Angelina Jolie curl interrupted.
I like peeps. Lou. It's spitting
out or antidepressants. You know,
cat tranquilizers are
actually a famous drug. Yeah.
Well what does it mean?
Yeah. Academy, but I don't
think she's on ketamine because,
because, uh, one of them,
my wife had it,
a syringe in her mouth and she got
some inner under government gone.
No. Hope it wasn't kicking
him. Jesus Christ. And, okay,
so you had to inject this fucking cat.
Well, you inject it in a, in a pill too.
Wow.
Inject your cat. Good fucking
luck. Why inject uh, uh,
the widow? Madeline paramin
gets her insulin twice a day.
You have a cat that needs insulin?
Yeah. Yeah. Whoa. Dude was 15 years old.
Holy Shit Man. I have a lot of
cats. How many cats do you have?
I have four cats, Jane. A lot
of cats. Joey Diaz has 11.
Oh really? That's a lot of,
oh, actually tag the is
about it. That's good. Oh,
Joey Diaz lives a two bedroom apartment
with 11 cat. Smells delicious.
It's beautiful. He says it cleans
the litter box every day. You got it.
That's not enough. I can, I got four.
I got four boxes. No waiting, you know?
Yeah. So two cats toolbox. W
what are your cats' names? Uh,
Oliver and Spazz spazz and wise fans was
that she's just, when she was a kitten,
shoes,
she would just run out of the room.
Like something was chasing her out of
nowhere. They're like clashing and things.
And she was always knocking things over.
She's 15 years old and she's
still asking a kitten. I, uh, I,
I probably am not so crazy about mankind,
but I haven't gotten a lot
of love for a little animals.
Every time I bring a cat home, my
wife's like, she goes, stop it.
She says you're the Schindler
of cats because you fight
cancer. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
Like squeaky Fromme. I had a dog named
squeaky Fromme. Yeah. Redhead. No.
Oh, she was a, she was a brown, but
he named her squeaky. Fromme yeah.
That doesn't make sense.
Squeaky Fromme had red hair.
Well, when I, when I met her,
uh, her, a voice was gone because she was
in the pound and when she was barking,
she lost her voice. Squeaky squeaky.
Squeaky. FROMME is because she'll
kill for me to feel for it.
I can tell it to kill. No, she, uh,
it's squeaky Fromme cause she's a dodgy
redhead that I found on the streets of
Hollywood. I didn't even know
the squeaky Fromme was a redhead.
I don't think I have, that was a wee bit
before my time, but she, she didn't act.
Did she actually attempt to kill no word.
No. Yeah, she tried to kill Ford. Yeah.
She wasn't on any of the creepy
crawly she wasn't on any of the, uh,
the Manson, uh, kills. She was
just, she lived at the spawn ranch.
And then,
uh,
I love the fact that I know all this about
her and I didn't know who the fucking
mayor was
it out. It goes Tonio of it. But uh,
yeah, so, so squeaky from Pete's Lu,
the, oh, the detective Carla Wisconsin.
That's the, uh, the latest cat and
they blamed all that stuff on, on uh,
LSD. Yeah, that's what
they blamed on. You know,
they blame this most recent Miami attack.
Did you see this guy a bit?
The guy's face off the white looking
animals. I did to see the photos.
Don't pull him up though. I don't show
them when you stream. How dare you. Um,
but the, um, the, there, the
police are saying that the
guy was on some new, crazy,
potent form of LSD. That's what
they're saying. But it's on Lsd at all.
It's this stuff called bath salts.
Do you know what Bass on?
So that's what he was on. Yeah, was
on bass off. It's, it's like a crystal
meth that you can sell
legally because they,
they modify one of the molecules.
So do you know like the for a long
time like bath salts, bath salts,
that's what they call it.
Okay.
They call it bath salts and they
can sell it in head shops and,
and in different places. But essentially
it's like a form of meth. It's,
it's really, and it's legal. See
if you have just one molecule,
something's different
from an illegal drug.
You can make like cousins that have
like very similar side effect or some
similar effects. And that's what
they've done. So they've is,
it's essentially like a
super potent form of meth.
And this guy took it and ate a guy's face.
But it does it make you,
does it make you hallucinate? I mean,
I don't know what the fuck it does too.
Obviously gas is a roast.
I think he just went fucking crazy.
I just think you were
absolutely crazy.
There was another guy,
I think that was unmet that cuts
some guys hard out recently. Yeah.
I think,
I think some people,
you get the right mind with the right
substance and they just completely lose
their shit.
But this guy who is eating the face, he
kept eating the face. That's why I to use.
Where are they? I mean he was, he was,
he's the guy, his whole face. You saw it,
right? Like people bite all
the time and the fighting. But,
but the fact that he was swallowing
and then went back for more,
he ate the guy's face. He held him
down, he ate his nose, you know,
and the guy was screaming and writing.
The guy was not unconscious.
I was conscious the whole
time he made his face.
He was conscious while the guy whose
face that silence of the lambs.
Yeah. And the guy, I mean he ate
his whole face or people don't know.
I mean these entire front of his
face is missing. His nose is missing.
His eyebrows are missing. The
guy just, it took a while.
The guy ate him for a while.
It's really incredible.
Mrs This guy part chimp.
Oh No, just a regular dude.
Well, we were all part chimp,
Bob. Apparently this,
you believe in the Bible.
We're all part of chimp apparently.
If you give me a red wine and
a bath salts and bath salts,
I might bite your face.
Yeah.
That's a wonder if this guy is
a squeaky clean record. Who?
The guy who bit the by
stuff. Here's his face. Now
for the folks who didn't want to
see that face and I didn't eat it,
I've seen it already. Oh, you saw
it. Sometimes I listen to the show.
I'm surprised and stuff that
you will watch and look at
things that are violent. You'll
say, hey, check this out.
There's a guy who gets his arm
ripped off or whatever. You know?
We'll look at them like tigers in a zoo.
Yeah.
Someone getting reaches in and take
a picture. Post hole fucking arm off.
I saw that video.
I like those videos and then
you play Yakety sax under him.
What's the Acne Benny Hill thing
makes anything funny. Getting your
arm ripped off at the zoo. Oh,
fucking silly. But again, the
guy who we have the guy reach in
or did the line just,
just grab a few of them out there?
There's a few videos.
I mean it an individual circumstances.
I think a lot of them,
when the guys were reaching in trying
to take pictures. Okay. One of them,
a guy got to close that he sat with his
back to the lions and so that they can
take a photo of him in the
lion's reach through Tim.
And as they pulled him close,
they bid him and then they got his arm
through and they just ripped his arm off
his body. Wow. Youtube.
Well a couple of them,
some of them were on live leak.
They're on different webs is like
they'll find them on youtube and they'll
remove them because they're so gorgeous.
There's so many things that are so
gory that I don't want him in my head.
You know what I mean?
And I know that when the Alzheimer's
kicks in, that will be the only
thing that'll be in a loop.
And last screen saver on my screen saver
will beat a guy getting his nuts chewed
up by tag or, and you know, I do
know that like when I'm senile,
like two girls and one cup is going to
be the only thing I can remember and
they'll be like,
let's not go see grandpa.
He just talks about girls
pooping and drinking it.
It's amazing that things like two girls,
one cup can be that viral.
That's something can literally hit and
millions and millions and millions of
eyes. Actually something like
that is what will cause world
piece. Or as you say, the hundredth
monkey, you know it will be two girls,
one cup. That'll be the universal. Yeah,
because it transcends nationalities
and that's where it starts.
That's where the revolution started.
I realize we're all the same cause
we're 100 million people have seen this
because we're laughing at the same
thing because we are not laughing,
but we all have the same reaction that
may stop wars that may turn everything
around.
Not everybody has the same reaction.
Some people were probably
beating off to that. Right.
I mean there's a reason why there's that
shit, that shit porn is out there, right,
Jack? Yeah. Do they beat off to
this? People are beating off the,
that face pic of that guy,
that Zombie guy.
Mm. Maybe. Maybe they are. It's probably
two people at least. Sure. That you,
if you could think it,
someone's doing that Japanese guy cut
his dick off and served it to booth,
you would say, no way. Just when we were
kids, you would say, no way. You know,
in the 1980s you'd say,
no, no one's doing that.
No one's cutting the dick off and
serving it. That's an urban myth.
But they are kind of wine. Do you serve
with that? I would say a white wine.
White wine. A lusty red wine.
What do you have? No Dick.
Now, if it was two buck, fuck
now if it was a woman's genitals,
it's definitely a fish. Yeah. Right.
So that would be a white wine. Dairy.
Well, it's an eel. An Eel. You would have
white wine with eal. How's your cock?
It's good. No, I really don't know.
You didn't eat all of it? I know.
Here's the thing, I just,
my eyes are bigger than my
stomach when I came in here.
Imagine if you had to throw some of his
cock in the garbage because he didn't
finish it. No one finished it. Reheating
the cock in the microwave the next day.
Don't take it so hard.
Awesome. Legal. How are you
allowed to serve people?
Human food now food
here. When she serve yourself?
I guess maybe it doesn't matter.
Is that the loophole for cannibalism?
I guess? I guess if you eat yourself,
I mean,
what's the difference between that and
when you chew the skin on your fingers?
Yeah,
my hair. Oh yeah, but that's if
you eat yourself. Who the fuck?
What kind of fucking doctor
moved that guy's cock? Where?
Where in hippocratic oath.
It was the same doctor that did
Kanye west mother's a lifeboat. Oh.
Oh, oh, oh no.
Oh no he didn't.
Well,
I mean what kind of doctor you said
like one out of a hot dick and that's
someone in a top notch hospital is
what I'm saying. That's not a doctor.
I mean a doctor supposed to. That's like
against the less in Japan is different.
Maybe they felt that this,
this guy probably hit some sort of mental
disorder that felt that his penis was
holding him back. So this guy was
helping them by removing his penis.
He said he was asexual.
You know that he does not,
not that he's not male or not female,
but both.
But what he meant was that he
has no desire for sex, nothing.
And then he had no need for his junk.
That's probably like abuse. Right?
Wouldn't you assume?
I'm guessing this guy was in his 50s no,
22 and you're done.
You're over your joining too.
Wow. Yeah. Wow. Yeah.
What kind of chef are you at?
currently didn't go to one
of the finer colon area.
Gave you a dick for later
when you're really good.
Yeah. When you know what you're
doing. Oh, I should have t boned it.
I should've butterflied it.
Now the way the sauce that I use now with
Kakuma, oh my goodness. Cock and balls,
everybody, all they said was they could
taste the butter. That's all they tasted.
There is no fenna get some moly.
Removes Cock fish sticks in his mouth.
This poor fucking guy, man. I mean,
just thinking of what a ridiculous idea
that is. The how years later. Well,
well, think about what you did in your
youth and then you, you know, I mean,
I mean now I don't feel bad about being
in police academy two and three and four.
I didn't cut my cock off
service. Yeah, this guy,
he had this, oh my God,
there's photos of it. Oh my
God, Dude. Okay. Heart chaos.
Go to Heart K. I'm not going to see
that. I don't care. Well it's, it's,
it's like Google has tapas food. I don't
want to see it. All right. Just Google it.
Need to look out. But he got it to look
exactly like, I don't want to see it.
Like if I get awesome boiled or
was it cooked? It looks like,
I don't want to tell you man. He's
slicing it up. It's hard core.
So it's like Shashimi oh,
it's cooks to cook Dick and
balls. This is horrific, man.
This guy is fucking Dick and balls off
and made people eat it and who's eating
it?
A bunch of people,
I think a lot about a lot of money per
per a table and now they're all in the
same frat. Oh, scary. It's pledge week,
motherfucker.
I just,
you know,
I would love to
just talk to the guy.
You sure man, let's,
let's think this over.
Even if you, you know, you
don't want to have sex anymore.
You don't have to remove your deck.
Like you could just not
upset an angry breakup. Yeah.
That's a really angry break.
His Dick did something. He's
like saying, you know, fuck you.
I'm going to eat my dick now.
Wow.
There's no laws against cannibalism
in Japan.
As long as you acquire that.
I'm guessing so you could like,
if someone donated their body when they
died, you could eat it. I guess you could.
Yeah. Jesus. So still frightening.
This is something crazy days.
After his 22nd birthday,
the artist's underwent elective general
removal surgery divided up to separate
penis shaft testicles and scrotal skin
between five people and garnished it with
button mushrooms and Italian Parsley.
I want that guy literally made people
eat his Dick Button mushrooms bold.
I would want would like an asparagus.
Wow. This is the spectrum, man.
This fits right in the spectrum.
There's no,
but I mean that's the bottom
or top of the spectrum,
whichever way you want to go.
You really think so.
I think the bottom is people
eating other people's dicks.
You think things have gotten
any weirder? I don't. I think,
I think we just now know about it.
I can't get exposure to different things.
It's certainly jaded people and it's
certainly reflected in porn and porn is
where people are naked and you
know seeking pleasure. Right? Well,
when you look at Porn,
you can see a clear change between the
way people were before the Internet and
the way people are after the Internet.
First of all, the porn industry vanished.
There is no industry anymore. It's
all like free stuff. It's all,
everything's online. It's free. Like very
few people are paying for it much less.
And second of all,
it's fucking violent man.
A lot of it is like choking and slapping
and gagging and an opening up your
eyelids and shooting Lowe's into
your eyes and shooting lows,
the glasses and making you drink.
Tell you I'm watching more than I've
ever paid for my life because of a web
webcams. Well yeah, but you're a, you're
a broken man. They're just more crazy.
[inaudible] you pay for web
cams. That's what you're
doing. Tipping girls. Oh, okay.
So you like getting on Webcam with
them? Well No, no. I may see you.
There's websites we've talked about before
where you just sit there and you know,
they're talking to you
back and forth and then,
and that's how you're beating off these
days. Hell yeah. Ben On these things. Oh,
it's the best for somebody that likes,
it's,
it's completely like heaven because you
fall in love with the girls and asking
me where are, you know,
but it's, it's, it's,
it's way better for anyone that
masturbates in porn wise now.
Cause now you get to
actually talk to the people.
It's like being at a strip club with
it, you know, you're, you're typing.
But uh, on some of them you can,
you pay for like a private room,
but it's more like,
it's like a huge chat room.
It's like watching this like on Ustream
where you're just sitting there getting
to know that girl.
The girl's talking back and forth
and you tipper like 20 tokens,
which is like a dollar. And then
she's like, oh, thank you. Oh here,
here's my tits out. What do you want?
All you have to depose a dog dude,
kind of third world. They think
Webcams, they've changed that.
They've changed it to like
where it's like a token amount.
Say it's really confusing. So,
uh, like kind of like Xbox.
So you might be into it a lot
more than you think. Yeah.
Well No, I mean I'll, I'll,
I'll, I'll, I'll put $20 into my
account and it'll last me a month.
And it's just like fucking chicks,
like hot,
normal girls that are in a lot of these
girls get to block the state that they
live in so that no one, their coworkers
don't know about it and stuff like that.
So these girls are just fucking normal
girls that like I just got off olive
garden,
capture them in video.
They don't know that they like
all these websites are saying
these tags, all these, all
these girls are saying,
cause I've actually heard people talk
about this before. It's like, oh no,
they have this protective,
you know, technology. So that
can't happen. And I'm like,
whenever I do it all the Chin and happen.
So these girls are
throwing away their lives.
And how far down the rabbit
hole of you gone? I mean do you,
do you $40 I mean have you talked to him
outside of the center? No, no, no, no, no.
They like using toys and stuff.
Was that what they do?
They're using toys that this one girl
has a fuck machine that she built that
looks like an erector set.
I don't know.
But it's using like I think imagine
trying to make that girl come. Yeah,
but it's awesome. So sit there
and just like it's broken callus.
Vagina is overstimulated
from this fucking machine,
but it's great.
Like the more you tip,
the faster she takes it and does
it. They're selling, these are,
these are girls like fucking trying to
sell some a new thing so she'll have this
fuck machine fucking are really
slow. And she's like, ah.
And then the more she gets in tips,
the faster she goes and then it goes to
like where she's just getting fucking
nailed. But she also just
made $1,000, you know,
so and it's completely free.
Like all these like my free cams,
all of this when I was
a young man did you,
but you know,
that's the thing to get the machine that's
fucking a woman that will get fucked
harder. It sort of backs up. My point
is that things, things are different.
They are different pistol to the fucking
fuck.
Rome, Rome, Rome, nothing on
that. Where are we going? Crazy.
That's a good question to you
are going to be a two years.
Um,
the Mysterians man,
the Mayan calendar man.
Well,
whatever the mines didn't predict
whatever it took them down.
So you know how good we
missed out on their shit.
Maybe their counter was like 12.
They actually recently found a
new version of the Mayan calendar,
even older that has
everything past December 21st,
2012 it's like we just saw it.
I mean they would like,
why keep going though the fuck
they live thousands of years ago.
Was that not ambitious enough that they
made a calendar up to 2012 this was me
is the end of the world.
They stopped here.
I don't even put anything three
months ahead on my Google calendar,
so I'm expecting the minds
get the blackout 2000 years.
December 21st,
2012 I think it's going to be another y
two k sort of situation. Remember that?
Everybody's terrified.
I think.
I haven't even given it any thought
to mind at all at all. I know who are,
you are concerned that there
is a possibility that we
could fuck up the world.
Then the next few years I do
question constantly like, you know,
where are we going as people like,
you know,
where just where are we going?
I mean I think, you know,
I know you're a fan of the technology,
but a lot of the technology I think
does help us isolate. You know,
people don't communicate people comment
and blog instead of actually use the
protocol of conversations,
which is like, you know,
there's boundaries when you're standing
next to someone talking, you know, and so,
and yeah,
I do wonder where we're going as people
this over entitled sense of where
everywhere you go you should be connected
into the Internet and not, you know,
you don't have to acknowledge the people
that are four feet in front of you.
It's weird, man. Well, the idea is
that they're mutually exclusive.
The idea is that you can't have ethics
and morals and be friendly and nice and
be on the Internet.
I think that's kind of silly.
I think what it is is we removed social
cues. We remove the interaction of the,
the one human to another where there's,
you have a direct result of the things
you say. You say something negative,
you see the person's face,
you feel it.
You don't feel shit when you just
rag on people from your snarky blog.
Right now you just write some country
words down designed to get some sparks.
And I think we could both
as comics relate to that.
We've all said things that we probably
didn't really necessarily mean,
but we knew we'd get a good response.
Like the guy who just made the
Cotonou s mom's joke. But the,
but here's the thing, I have to
feel the repercussions from that.
If he comes after me,
I have to apologize because I did step
over the line honestly when I said that.
Right. So, but the anonymous nature
of it makes it okay. You know, and,
and that's, that's, that's just a
tiny part of it. I mean, really it is,
but I don't think it's necessary.
I think a,
I think you can surround
yourself with a group of people.
Even online if you construct your own,
like
I have a message board and I try the
hardest I can to cut all the cons out.
Well then whenever people just start
getting really insulting for no reason,
a shitty or does negative, I just,
I get rid of them, I cut them out,
I send them to a pink room,
I have a room where they,
their names are all pink and this is
now they can only post in this new place
called the cont farm. And then, you
know, it tries as hard as, I mean,
it's not completely,
it's not flawless. The,
it's still a lot of assholes
slipped through the cracks.
But I have a friend who's on social media
and she's in show Biz, I'd say. And uh,
people will post or tweet something about
her and she'll respond and then they
always back down and
they go, oh, well I, oh,
I didn't know you were trying to get a
rise out of, but it just seems so crazy.
And then it gives people feel inadequate
and they feel like someone is doing
something that they can't do or on a
television show, and they can find,
they're not in the same situation as
that person, but they find a flaw,
they find a weakness, they find
something and they just lash out.
And what they're really lashing
out. It's not that, you know,
her acting is so atrocious.
It really drives him nuts to the point
where he's going to lash out and attacker,
no, it's just he's, he's a, he hates
his own life. He hates his own life. So
everybody's saying I exist and
stuff and, and a lot of, yeah,
I understand all that. But I
don't even think that's the, the,
the fact that we really are, I don't
know where we're going. I mean, really,
you know, and you ask yourself in
my part of the problem, or am I,
and where am I contributing to it?
I mean,
I'm not on social media and I don't
think of that as you were for a while.
We are on Twitter for a while. No, those
are fake. There's been fake mes, you know,
which kicking off the fake me,
it was pretty funny because it was so,
it was such a huge hassle where
I had to send in my passport,
sang that I'm me giving out my passport
information, you know what I mean?
That's kind of weird.
Twitter to Twitter to prove that I'm me,
you know? So yeah. And, and
I, you know, I have said like,
why would you say you're me in cyberspace?
Cause my daughter wants came in backward
and you know, my space, she's like, Dad,
there's some guy trying to get pussy
saint. He's on my space. I was like,
oh well we got to stop him. No,
but it really wasn't me. But,
but yeah, just recently I kicked the guy
off Twitter, a couple Twitter things,
you know, how come you have no desire? Um,
because I really don't give a shit what
po or you're 69 thanks in me. And uh,
the other part of it is,
is I already know that it's a warm hole.
I would go down and not come back out.
You know,
like I would rather spend my time
being creative now as a comedian.
I really should be out there so I could
plug my dates and all that stuff. But,
but I think it's the exposure to be
that exposed to people, uh, that,
that I don't like the idea of
that. And then also, um, it,
it feels like another job,
you know,
the constantly writing material
and posting it and stuff, you know,
don't have to constantly,
one
of the things that happens is developed
like a little community and they send
you cool shit and you can
just retweet them. You know,
sometimes when I'm running around in
the day and I don't have time to write
anything and put it on Twitter,
but I'll occasionally check in
and I get these really weird,
crazy tweets where people send
me some, you know, naughty,
fascinating thing and I'll retweet
it. And then, you know, they'll,
it develops like a whole community of
people like looking out for that stuff and
people that, like that stuff. And
every, you know, and I think it,
it provides a service to,
it provides a connection.
You know you're the catalyst and you
connect all these hundreds of thousands of
people together and the exchange ideas.
I think that's nothing but good.
You know the,
the,
the thing about it is trying to
make sure that you don't overuse it.
You know,
you don't,
you could get stuck on Twitter all day
just responding to people and never and
never leave your office and never,
never leave in front of the computer.
You really could share.
Of course you got to learn how to walk
away at a certain point in time for sure.
And you know, got to learn how to not not
let it be obsessive, but as a comedian,
it's an amazing tool. You still do morning
radio and all that kind of stuff. Yeah.
Yeah. You don't have to
do that if you ever, ever,
and I have to do it anywhere it's
going to play out is really good.
Twitter and podcasts to dragged
that. Yeah. We don't have,
we don't do that anymore. Like we
have a show tonight that Joe put up,
start talking about yesterday
and it's almost sold out. Yeah.
We just decided to do a show. We said,
oh, we're going to do it. By the way,
if you want to get it, get tickets now.
It's already should fear Joey Diaz, me,
Christina [inaudible] is John [inaudible].
John Heffrons,
not by Randy licky from
bones on us. Powerful. It's,
it's a serious show and it's only 15 bucks
and it's at the Ice House comedy club,
which is one of the oldest clubs,
if not the oldest in the country.
This place started in 1950 and uh,
it's just a super cool
club filled with the,
everyone that works here is like really
nice. It's like a good vibe place, right?
Who says we love doing the
podcast here? Yeah. It's like,
it's such a warm environment. It's
like they're cool people. So you'll,
you'll like coming here and so it's
a big show tonight at 10 o'clock.
Anything else ma'am? No, that's it.
That you can get my new movie.
Uh,
God bless America and Vod and, uh,
all the other movies are on Netflix.
Sleeping dogs lie. World's greatest
dad. All my movies have last.
The world's greatest dad.
Uh, God bless America.
My buddy of mine a build a labs like a,
as soon as the next one it
would be I'm with stupid
tee shirt or a coffee mug series.
Is that what you doing when you're doing?
No, I don't know why. I mean I,
I'm going to probably break it soon and
make a movie without a three name title.
Could fit on a t shirt.
Yeah. If you come back again,
I promise you I will see world's greatest
dad and I will see God bless America.
We will discuss both of them
next time we come back. Cool man.
Thanks for having me. Yeah. Oh, it was
a lot of fun, man. I really enjoyed it.
I appreciate it very
much. Thank you. Bobcat.
Goldthwait Ladies and gentlemen and thank
you to the fleshlight for sponsoring
our lovely podcast. That's it for the
week. We gave you three this week.
You've dirty freaks. Um, next
week. I don't know who we got.
We got some people coming up though.
John Anthony West is June 7th,
so a that's not next week. Right?
That's like a couple of weeks.
I don't know who we got next week.
I've got some people online though.
Maybe we'll get Brad,
Brad Williams.
We got a Lotta Lotta Fun shit coming
up though, ladies and gentlemen.
So thanks to a, the fleshlight
for sponsoring our podcast.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight
and enter in the code name. Rogan is,
save yourself some
money, 15% off. Exactly.
Also thank you to [inaudible]
dot com that's o n n I t,
makers of Alpha Brain shroom, tech
sport shroom, tech immune. Well,
I shouldn't even list all the supplements
because we've got a lot of new shit
coming to and eventually it's going to be
stupid. I'm not a fucking catalog. Okay.
On a.com oh and and it used the code
rogue and save 10% off any and all orders.
That's it. The show's over ice house
tonight. Ice House tonight. Yeah.
10 o'clock show. Oh, and if you
want, if you get here at eight 30,
Joey Diaz has a one man show.
Like he tells stories in the or.
So you could have a,
a double desk squad evening.
Uh,
that's at eight 30 rides that sold out
as Joey Solano. I'm not sure. All right.
All right. We love you guys. We'll see
you soon. [inaudible] by my desk. Oh yeah.
Go to [inaudible] dot
TV. Buy The shirt. Oh,
and if you want to see the icehouse
chronicles tonight, I'm going to be on,
but a little bit later, um, go
to, uh, [inaudible]. They're
only available on iTunes.
If you go to a iTunes,
subscribe to death squad and you can
get that the ice house chronicles,
and it just counts for 50% off.
Your mother's can't go fuck yourself.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Go crabbing.
[inaudible].